und wie kommst du da drauf ich habe noch gar nichts wirklich gespielt auf der neuen kiste
ich habe gestern den stream ausgemacht und das war's mehr habe ich danach nicht mehr mitgemacht
die liegt immer noch hier neben mir ich muss mir auch mal angucken dass das die zweite platte
richtig erkennt oder wisst ihr was ich mir auch überlegt habe was er machen könnte man könnte
einfach dual boot machen mit einem windows und steam drauf falls man doch mal was spielen will
was windows only ist oder vielleicht irgendwelche neuen emulator dinger braucht ihr und die diesen
unter windows gibt oder so keine ahnung weil für meine games da reichen 500 g war sowas von locker
aus ich will ja dann nicht mal großartig xbox obwohl man es spielen könnte theoretisch glaub
das erste das erste gs vorläuft auf dem xbox emulator halbwegs also die die games sind ja
alle nicht gut
groß ich meine so ein n64 game ist keine ahnung wo sind die 20 mb das ist ja nix und selbst ein
ps1 game ist maximal wie 650 700 mb je nachdem was sie für eine cd verwenden also kriegst du einiges
unter raspberry pi das reicht ganz knapp für n64 und auch nicht alles der raspberry pi ist
tatsächlich kein gute keine gute
base dafür also wenn wenn die erreicht ähnót und ist einemeye hess und 16 bit konsollen dann
ist okay alles andere aber so seine probleme mit und upscaling ist schon mal gar nicht
also bei 60 bitcoin so ganz abstellen aber 60 centro bringt ab scania so das lohnt sich nicht
dann hol dir lieber irgend eine günstige x86 emulator kiste
Also x68 Spaced Emulator Kiste
Auch was billiges
Ist schneller als ein Raspberry Pi
Und besser
Also ein Raspberry Pi 4 schafft mit Acht und Krach
Ein N64
Da sieht man mal wie viel leistungsfähiger
Als ein Raspberry Pi die kleine Kiste hier ist
Die kostet auch mindestens 550 Euro
Gut ein Raspberry Pi
Was kostet nicht aktuell ein Raspberry Pi
Wenn du einen kriegst
Ein 4 bis 8G RAM
Wahrscheinlich auch 80 Euro
Was es überhaupt nicht wert ist
Wenn das Ding den Originalpreis kostet
Würde voll und ganz okay
Aber zu den aktuellen Preisen lohnt sich der Raspberry Pi einfach null
Dann fährst du mit einem Mini PC
Oder irgendwelche Low Power Intel Kisten
Tatsächlich besser
Das lohnt sich aktuell gar nicht
Das einzige wofür es sich halt lohnt
Wenn du irgendein spezielles
Spezielles Header Modul hast
Was nur auf den Raspberry Pi passt
Und weißt was ich
Wenn es dafür dann nur die Software gibt
Und dafür nur Tutorials gibt
Und so vielleicht
Aber
Das meiste gibt es ja für alles
Es macht ja keiner Software meistens
Das meistens
Explizit für einen Raspberry Pi
Es ist ganz viel Python Zeug
Das läuft potenziell eigentlich überall drauf
Aber klar es gibt spezielle Header Boards
Die nur auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen
Oder spezielle Cases zum Beispiel
Um es auf die Hutschiene zu machen
Manchmal ist es sicherlich sinnvoll
Einen Raspberry Pi zu nehmen
Da muss dann aber auch kein 4er sein
Aber preislich lohnt sich das aktuell
Überhaupt gar nicht
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken
Bury Base
Ne nicht Bury
Bury
Haben die überhaupt welche
Ich sollte mal einen Dark Reader
Die haben überhaupt keine mehr oder
Derzeit nicht lieferbar
Nicht lieferbar
Der nächste Raspberry Pi
Der lieferbar sein wird
Ist der Raspberry Pi 5 oder
Das lohnt sich
Alter das ist doch nicht mehr normal
Hoh
Schwappen
Hahaha
Alles klar
Dafür kriegst du super super Power
Powerfull super super schneller
X86 lau
Powerkiste
Also ganz ehrlich Raspberry Pi kannst du komplett vergessen
aktuell
Einfach komplett
Ich bin froh dass ich für Bastelzwecke noch zwei Raspberry Pi 4s hier habe
Die werde ich auch nicht für irgendetwas verwenden
Die bleiben für keine Chance für mich in mir drin
fürs basteln erhalten bis es mal wieder bis es mal wieder was gibt weil dafür
sind die wirklich gut die sind auch beide in so einem schönen in so einem
schönen leer case knapp beinahe beinahe hätte ich das jetzt auch noch diese
schließen kakt dieser schließen button da oben ist einer markt windows 11 echt
nicht ja die sind auch beide in so einem schönen flieg case passiv gekühlt
also lohnt sich überhaupt überhaupt gar nicht was bei mir als aktuell da würde
ich dann würde ich tatsächlich eher auf etwas anderes gucken es gibt ja andere
single board computer und ganz im ernst ich würde mir intel intel based low
power oder amd based low power hardware angucken
du kannst du kannst für diese sachen easy easy was war selbst bauen aber
manchmal ist es auch so dass man sich nicht so gut an die hardware anguckt
meistens nicht gescheit in dem formfaktor das beste was du selbst
bauen kannst ist so ist irgend so eine mikro mikro atx mini die sind ja auch
relativ klein aber nicht ganz so klein gebrauchte sind kleines funktionieren
wenn man so emulationstäusch machen will auch wunderbar halt auch nicht wirklich
also die schaffen zwar n64 aber danach als meistens auf er sehe nach dem was
man was man machen will muss man muss man gucken aber viele sind klein sind
tatsächlich eine ganz gute alternative für das body
bei und brauchen auch gar nicht so viel mehr strom wo es natürlich aufhört ist
wenn du gps brauchst das ist ja eigentlich das was den last body
ursprünglich mal so interessant gemacht hat dass du was ich wie viel hatten der
30 oder 20 oder 20 gps oder 24 ich weiß nicht wie viel gps laden der 40 40 40 gpr
Also dafür ist der Raspberry Pi natürlich so ungeschlagen, was das angeht, weil das hast du auf normaler Hardware halt nicht.
Schon auf irgendeinem kleinen oder Mini-PC hast du das halt nicht.
Du könntest halt höchstens mit einem ESP32 dran, aber da hast du halt kein vollwertiges Linux und keinen vollwertigen Rechner.
Also das hat durchaus Sinn, hat durchaus Sinn, aber aktuelle Preise vom Raspberry Pi sind einfach so komplett jenseits von gut und böse.
Das kannst du dir eigentlich nicht sinnvoll erklären, sich das zu kaufen.
Sind das die Atomdinger gewesen? N5000?
Äh, ne, die Atomteile waren...
Die Atomdinger wurden ja mittlerweile umbenannt in Celeron sogar.
Also Celerons gibt es jetzt... Bei Intel blickst du eh nicht mehr durch.
Also manches, was früher Atom war, heißt jetzt Celeron.
Zum Beispiel diese Dinger, das waren für Atom.
Celeron.
CPUs, jetzt sind es Celeron.
Was auch... Da blickt wirklich nur noch... Wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal Intel blickt da durch.
Die J-Dinger, die sind ganz gut. Da hatte ich selbst zwei Jahre eins im Einsatz.
Hier so eine Low-Power-Kiste.
Da hatte ich ein Board mit PCI-Express drauf und hatte eine 10G-Karte drin.
Und das ging ganz gut.
Ich meine, das ging jetzt nicht bis tatsächlich da wirklich 10 Gigabit, aber 600, 700 MB hat man trotzdem durchgekriegt über das Netzwerk.
Wohlgemerkt mit einem Quad-Core und dann auch mit Festplattenverschlüsselung.
Was für eine Kiste. Sowas hier.
Sowas hatte ich ja selbst eine Weile im Einsatz.
Allerdings mit weniger SATA-Ports und dafür einem vollen Slot.
Allerdings war der auch bloß xx, also zweifach, zweifach angebunden.
Und es ist auch nur PCI-Express 2.
Muss man ein bisschen gucken. Mal gucken, wie die...
Was zum Teufel ist eigentlich los mit der S-Rock-Seite?
Was hat denn die S-Rock-Seite für Probleme?
Aber was Neues haben die nicht, wie es aussieht.
Okay.
Gemini Lake Refresh.
Apollo Lake sind noch die älteren.
Ja, und das sind nur PCI-Express 2.
Nicht so, nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Und da habe ich irgendwas verpasst die Woche, Leute.
Lass mal Github-Trends schnell gucken.
Github.
Moment.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Issues übersehen habe.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich müsste vielleicht mal ein paar Sachen fixen.
Ich habe schon erst von drei Monaten her, wo ich da zuletzt geupdatet habe.
Explore.
Trends.
Zeig her.
What's popular in Github?
Trending.
Zeig mal her.
Trended diese Woche.
Also, was gibt es hier wieder?
Instruct Pics to Pics.
Ich habe seriously keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ah ja, no description.
Ah, Machine Learning.
Was sonst?
Nuxt.
Ah, Vue.
Vue.js Zeug.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Eine Vim-Config.
Okay.
Nochmal Machine Learning.
Maschinenlernung.
Lernung.
Crypto.
Maschinenlernung.
AI-Kram.
Also, wenn man sich aktuell nicht für Krypto-Kram und AI-Kram interessiert.
Großartig.
Großartig ist Github gerade.
Die Github-Trends die letzten paar Monate sind nicht so spannend.
Guck mal, es ist alles voll.
Besteht nur aus AI-Zeug.
Ich meine, es ist verständlich.
Aber es wäre trotzdem ganz gut, wenn man ein bisschen wieder was anderes trenden würde.
So zwischendurch mal.
Maschinenlernung.
Oh, eine Sache.
Und das Windows-Terminal.
Na ja, geil.
Okay, hat sich.
Haben wir gleich.
Können wir gleich sein lassen.
Okay.
Kenn ich mich nicht aus.
Ich hab JackMK mal installiert.
Im Docker-Container laufen lassen.
Ein bisschen rumzuklicken, um mir das anzugucken.
Aber noch nie wirklich betrieben.
Keine Ahnung von.
Ich hab bei mir lokal in Zabbix.
Ist auch nicht der Weiße als letzter Schluss, ehrlich gesagt.
Die Config vom Zabbix ist halt richtig abfuck.
Schade, dass es irgendwie keine ordentlich bedienbare Monitoring-Lösung gibt.
Irgend so eine Mischung aus Prometheus-Exporter, Grafana und so weiter.
Das ist halt auch mehr, wir bauen uns ein Monitoring-System selbst, als was Fertiges.
Außerdem ist es eher für Metriken und weniger für Hostess up und down.
Auch wenn es auch geht.
Aber schön ist es nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das Amazon-Stuff war.
Ja.
Warum Nagios nicht mehr im Trend ist.
Wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich wegen der Config.
Ich persönlich mag Nagios.
Ich würde jetzt heute vielleicht keine neue Nagios-Installation mehr machen.
Aber an sich.
An sich mochte ich Nagios immer.
Echt.
Dann ist es ja gut.
Ich habe immer gedacht, die Leute pennen dadurch nochmal extra ein.
Weil ich bin Sonntagsmorgens meistens nicht sonderlich fit.
Home-Server-Rack.
Moment, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich ohne Scheiß, jetzt habe ich mir zwei Reviews angeguckt.
Zu...
Mini-PCs.
Und jetzt ist YouTube der Meinung, guck Mini-PC-Videos, guck Mini-PC-Videos.
Okay.
2023 top CLI-Tools you need to know.
Wir skippen, wir skippen das jetzt ein bisschen.
Also top CLI-Tools you need to know.
Ich...
Okay.
AM.
AM ist ein Pogger-CLI-Tool.
Ah, hier sieht man es schon.
Okay.
Zelle...
Okay, das ist, das fällt bei mir raus mit dem neuen Terminal.
Brauche ich nicht mehr.
Just...
Forehead.
DM.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist irgendwas in Go programmiertes, um...
Ich glaube, automatisch Environment-Variablen pro Verzeichnis zu setzen oder sowas.
Braucht man nicht.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Was ist das?
Configuration Management braucht man auch nicht.
Also für Dot-File, für eine lokale Kiste.
Nee, unklar.
Braucht man nicht.
Ja, nice.
Okay, wir wissen, dass wir das Video nicht angucken müssen.
Ja, meine ich ja.
Meine ich ja.
Gibt es ja nicht.
Ich meine, Zabbix ist tatsächlich...
Checkmk wahrscheinlich auch.
Da habe ich aber nicht so viel Plan von.
Zabbix ist eine relativ gute All-in-One-Lösung.
Spätestens seit die auch Prometheus-Exporter konsumieren können.
Das Dumme an Zabbix ist, dass die Zabbix-Config einfach eklig ist.
Übers Web-Interface.
Also, das ist wirklich maximal, maximal verwirrend aufgebaut und benannt auch alles.
Bösewix, danke für den Sub.
Pogu.
Ja.
Und dann war die Woche irgendwas Spannendes.
Irgendwas, irgendwas verpasst.
Es gab doch irgendwelche Daten-Leaks wieder.
PayPal.
Hatte PayPal nicht irgendeinen Daten-Leak letztens?
Ich erinnere mich an News dazu.
Telekom USA.
Naja, ich glaube die Woche, war nichts.
Heise hatte doch so irgendeinen Wochenüberblick, den finde ich aber nicht.
Weiß nicht.
Was war das?
finde ich aber nie wochen wochen rückblick replay genau ja aber nicht von 2018 und irgendwas was
aktuelles da blickst du wieder nicht durch 27 erster youtube hat auch nichts spannendes
ultra chip 300 dollar hackintosh bild juckt mich überhaupt nicht alexis ist die letzte
war ich mir jetzt angucke fz 5000 gadgets das ist wahrscheinlich auch total uninteressant aber
mal gucken könnte zumindest irgendwas halbwegs spannendes sein was verdient ein kfz meister
wenn ihm der laden gehört wahrscheinlich ganz gut ok leute was ist hier los aber heute ist
es fünf jahre alt
des russischen hacker break into your computer in minutes ok ok ok das ist bestimmt das video
also wir gucken jetzt der russischen hacker zu wie unser computer einbricht das ding mit
hydro hype moment hydro hype war das nicht vor vor
drei jahren oder so ging es nach hydro hype weiter aha ok da gibt es jetzt ein okay wir
müssen wir müssen jetzt gucken wie uns wie uns der der russische hacker in minuten hackt
diese beiträge sind immer so cringe alter
okay auf
normal
hotel
traten und ganz zum team von
Ja, super, effect wireless point, super gehackt, Schabba.
Nur echte Ergaments können das.
Oh Mann, Alter, Leute, alles klar, in Minutes, in Minutes.
Genau, guck mal hier.
Basically, to get hacked in minutes, you just have to do things you never would.
What makes totally sense.
Das dachte ich mir auch gerade.
Oh Mann, diese Videos, das merkst du schon, das merkst du schon, wie das anfängt.
Oh, Alter, schreit nicht so rum.
Also manche, also mehr Clickbait, please.
Ja, vor allem hätt ihr VPN und sowas da wahrscheinlich sogar was gebracht.
Also wenn die Verbindung funktioniert hätte.
Hydro, Hydro.
Ich kann mich anders.
Was war das denn nochmal?
War das, wartet mal, lass mal, das war kein Energy Drink, ne?
War das die Creme?
Ich versuche mich gerade wieder dran zu erinnern, was das war.
Das war irgendeine Creme, die er irgendwelchen Instagram Influencern verkaufen wollte, oder?
Die Creme, die Kleidkehl war.
Genau, und woran er denen erzählt hat.
Und was sie sagen sollen.
Und wenn ich mich richtig dran erinnern kann, das Verwerfliche daran war nochmal was,
dass die alle so getan haben, als war es nicht gesponsert, oder was war nochmal das Verwerfliche?
Ich kann mich nur noch ganz, ganz dunkel dran erinnern,
dass sie das nicht klar als Sponsoring gekennzeichnet haben,
so nach dem Motto, ah, ich hab das zufälligerweise gefunden und finde das ganz toll.
Oder was war nochmal?
Was war nochmal das Problem daran?
Manchmal irgendwelche Produktplacements sind ja jetzt wenig skandalös 2023.
Okay, dass sie nicht gesponsert werden.
Okay, zeigt mal her, 12 Minuten, können wir uns mal geben.
Herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem Zweitkanal, endlich wieder mit einem brandneuen Video.
Heute geht es um das legendäre Thema Hydrohype.
Ich glaube, das ist das Projekt, für das mich die meisten kennen.
Ich sage mal so, es ist Fluch und Segen zugleich.
Weil auf der einen Seite habe ich mit Hydrohype,
die Messlatte für mich selber, unfassbar hoch gesetzt.
Das merke ich an zwei, drei Stellen und zwar die erste ist,
dass ich selber mit meinen Videos und den Projekten, die ich anfange, mega unzufrieden bin,
weil ich halt immer wieder mich verbessern möchte, immer noch krasser werden möchte als bei Hydrohype.
Und das kann einem einfach auf lange Sicht gar nicht gelingen.
Und das zweite ist einfach auch die Außenwahrnehmung.
Die Leute, die mich für Hydrohype kennen, erwarten, dass ich am besten jede Woche so ein Projekt auf die Beine stelle.
Ja gut, kannst du ja vergessen.
Aber!
Aber bevor ich hier noch in Tränen ausbreche,
möchte ich natürlich auch noch mal das ganze Thema Hydrohype Revue passieren lassen, denn es ist hinter dem...
Ja genau, erklär für Noobs, für mich noch mal, um was es eigentlich ginge.
Ich habe schon wieder die Hälfte vergessen.
... noch einiges passiert.
Aber für alle, die es vielleicht nicht mitbekommen haben,
ich habe eine Fellcreme Hydrohype ins Leben gerufen und zwar im Jahr 2021.
Da habe ich die erfunden, habe mir einfach so einen Cremetiegel bestellt, habe Etiketten drucken lassen, habe...
Stimmt, das war das mit Kleidgel.
Genau, genau, ich erinnere mich wieder.
... die Inhaltsstoffe drucken lassen, aber auch erfundene Sachen wie Uran, Pipikaka Seed Oil und Asbest.
Stimmt, jetzt kann ich mich wieder erinnern.
... einfach weil ich Influencer testen wollte.
Und da kommen wir auch schon zur ersten Frage, die mir immer wieder gestellt wird.
Wie kamst du damals auf die Idee?
Und es ist eigentlich ganz banal.
Ich bin selbst einfach großer YouTube- und Instagram-Suchti, mittlerweile auch TikTok natürlich,
und sehe einfach, dass dort immer mehr Werbung läuft.
Werbung, und das ist auch wichtig zu betonen, ist nicht schlecht.
Werbung ist erstmal neutral.
Nur, wer sich für die Werbung hingibt und wie die Werbung konzipiert wird,
da scheidet sich tatsächlich die Spreu vom Weizen, denn da muss man darauf achten...
Neutral kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, aber er hat schon recht.
Es kommt darauf an, wie es verkauft wird und vor allem, ob es gekennzeichnet ist als Werbung.
Mick, danke schön für den Zap.
Aber ich finde das alles okay, solange es erkennbar ist, dass es Werbung ist.
Es ist zwar teilweise etwas merkwürdig, wenn man dann...
Ja, irgendwelche Paarungen sieht, die nicht so passen, irgendwelche Security-Channels, die NordVPN anpreisen und...
Oder...
Ja, aber letztlich ist es kein Ding, weil mache ich selbst.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als war ich super scharf drauf.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie dieses komische Mobile-Game hieß, was ich war.
Wo ich mal 60 Sekunden was...
Wie hieß denn das?
Dieser komische Pegel-Klon da.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Nicht Coin Master.
Nein, Raid Shadow Legends war es auch nicht.
Wie hieß das denn?
Ich habe es komplett verdrängt schon wieder.
Match Master, genau.
Ja.
Match Master.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich super scharf drauf gewesen wäre, irgendein Match Master Sponsoring zu machen.
Aber...
Wir haben ganz ordentlich bezahlt.
Sonst mache ich die Sachen ja prinzipiell nicht.
Es ist mir auch irgendwie zu schade und ich will die Videos nicht mit Werbung vollkleistern.
Ja, Match...
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich da scharf drauf gewesen bin, ja.
Und ich würde das normalerweise nie spielen.
Aber ich meine, man hat das in den 60 Sekunden halt mal ein bisschen angepriesen.
Und ich glaube niemand, der das wirklich...
Der mich wirklich guckt, war der Meinung, ich bin voll überzeugt, ich spiele jeden Tag Match Masters.
Aber gut.
Es ist als Werbung gekennzeichnet, das ist für mich das Wichtige.
Es ist...
Also wenn ich ein Video sehe, wo einer irgendwas anpreist und ich sehe, dass das Werbung ist, ist mir das vollkommen recht.
Was ich fragwürdig finde und was sicherlich rechtlich auch problematisch ist, wenn du Werbung quasi als so persönliches, persönliches verkaufst.
So nach dem Motto nicht, es ist Werbung und man sieht, dass es Werbung ist, sondern...
Oh, ich habe zufällig diese tolle Uhr heute im Aldi gefunden.
Das ist die schönste Uhr, die ich je gesehen habe.
Und du weißt halt nicht, dass das ein gesponsortes Uhrenplacement ist.
Dass man einfach das Ganze kritisch hinterfragt und guckt, wofür kann ich denn mit meinem Gesicht stehen.
Und nicht einfach zu gucken, wie viel Geld gibt es dafür.
Ja, ich sage alles, was der Kunde sagt.
Hey, eins muss ich jetzt an der Stelle nochmal sagen.
Ich habe das früher auch deutlich, deutlich kritischer gesehen.
Ja, also zu Zeiten, wo ich auf YouTube angefangen habe.
Ja.
War es ja fast noch verpönt, YouTube-Partner zu werden.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch dran.
Also wer Partner wurde, war geldgeil und sowas.
Damals konnte noch keiner sich so wirklich drüber Gedanken machen, dass man mal als...
Das Wort Influencer gab es damals noch gar nicht, ja.
Content Creator.
Dass man damit...
Wir reden ja noch nicht mal von reich werden, sondern von...
Man könnte davon eigentlich...
Man könnte quasi professioneller Content Creator auf YouTube werden.
Man verdient seinen Lebensunterhalt damit.
Das haben sich die meisten damals nicht wirklich vorstellen können.
Und dementsprechend hat man das natürlich alles auch ein bisschen kritischer gesehen.
Mittlerweile denke ich mir halt ja, die Leute müssen halt gucken.
Gerade die, die das hauptberuflich machen.
Die müssen halt gucken, wie sie hinkommen.
Und manchmal musst du da wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Sponsorings machen, die du persönlich nicht so geil findest.
Weil du hast die Auswahl.
Entweder du kommst gut über die Runden.
Oder nicht.
Und wenn du nicht über die Runden kommst, machst du vielleicht auch mal das ein oder andere Placement.
Wo du jetzt normalerweise denkst, ach so geil ist das aber nicht.
Aber was willst du machen?
Du bist ja komplett auf Gedeih und Verderben von diesem ganzen Ökosystem abhängig.
Als Vollzeit Content Creator.
Das heißt, du musst auch deine Streaming-Zeiten machen.
Du musst auch deine Content-Produktion einhalten.
Ob du Bock hast oder nicht.
Ob dich gerade alles abfuckt oder nicht.
Das ist egal.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass sich das viele Leute zu idealisiert vorstellen.
So nach dem Motto, ich bin jetzt ein 12-Jähriger in der Schule.
Guck mir gerne Streams an.
Würde gerne selbst Streamer werden.
Und kann mir eigentlich nichts besseres vorstellen, wie den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen und streamen.
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob du vorm Rechner sitzt und streamst, weil du gerade vorm Rechner sitzen willst und streamst.
Oder ob du jetzt vorm Rechner sitzen musst und jetzt streamen musst, ob du willst oder nicht.
Oder jetzt irgendwas aufnehmen musst, dir irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen musst.
Also das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Und auf Dauer ist das belastender, als sich viele vorstellen können.
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Ich bin halt in der komfortablen Situation, dass ich weder das eine noch das andere wirklich machen müsste.
Aber ich merke es auch schon teilweise.
Ich habe jetzt zwölf Tage kein Video mehr gemacht auf YouTube.
Ich habe eine große Themenliste.
Also ich könnte jetzt was aufnehmen.
Aber irgendwie habe ich gerade nicht so wirklich Bock, mich jetzt hinzusetzen.
Und ich merke es jetzt aber auch.
Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich mal.
Und bei mir ist es nur ein reines, wie soll ich sagen.
Ich müsste mal allein schon, dass die Leute wieder ein Video bekommen.
Und bei anderen ist es so, ich müsste mal, dass ich, jetzt ist übertrieben gesagt, dass ich mir was zu essen kaufen kann.
Also es ist schon ein Unterschied, wie abhängig man als Vollzeit-Content-Creator davon ist.
Aber muss man dafür seine Follower belügen?
Naja, wenn du es als Werbung kennzeichnest, machst du das ja nicht.
Also wenn da steht, diese 60 Sekunden ist Werbung.
Gut, dann ist es eher eine prinzipielle Frage.
Wie ist der Inhalt der Werbung?
Weil guckt in Fernsehen, da steht dann auch, stand dann auch früher Michael Schumacher und hat Werbung gemacht.
Oder es stehen irgendwelche anderen Sportprofis da, die dir erzählen, oh, ich benutze jetzt Alpecin in meinem Haar und alles ist ganz geil.
Also das ist ja auch nichts anderes.
Aber es ist halt wichtig, dass es als Werbung zu erkennen ist.
Das ist gar nicht so extrem, wie es immer getan wird.
Ich hatte schon immer Phasen, wo ich wochenlang, teilweise monatelang nichts gemacht habe und dann ein Video hochgeladen habe.
Wenn es ein gutes Thema ist, was die Leute interessiert, klappt das.
Also YouTube hat das mittlerweile im Griff.
Was problematisch ist, du hast so ein bisschen einen Motivationskiller, wenn du längere Zeit nichts gemacht hast.
Also längere Zeit reden wir hier von drei, vier Monaten plus.
Also wenn du mal so ein Quartal oder so nichts hochgeladen hast, dann hast du das Problem, dass ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, woran das liegt.
Aber es ist so, weil ich das selbst schon gemerkt habe, dass YouTube deinen Kanal erstmal irgendwie in so einen Schlaf- oder Inaktivmodus setzt.
Was bedeutet, dass auch deine Analytics und deine Counter und so alles nur noch sehr unregelmäßig aktualisiert wird und geupdatet wird.
Und auch Leute, die ihr Account geschlossen haben, werden nicht richtig von den Abonnenten abgezogen und sowas.
Sondern das erste, was passiert ist.
Wenn du mal so drei, vier Monate inaktiv warst, du lädst was hoch.
Und selbst wenn es ein richtig gutes Video ist, du kriegst innerhalb der ersten 24 Stunden erstmal 50 bis 200 Unsubs.
Einfach so.
Das liegt, glaube ich, mal gar nicht daran, weil alle Leute unsubben.
Warum sollen die auf einmal unsubben?
Weil die haben ja für den gleichen Content vor auch gesubbt und machen es ja normalerweise auch nicht.
Sondern weil YouTube erstmal anfängt, irgendwelche Sachen nachzumachen.
Nachzufahren jetzt auf deinem Account, wenn du wieder aktiv wirst.
Zum Beispiel wird dann YouTube erstmal checken.
Okay, manche haben ihren Account geschlossen.
Wir aktualisieren das jetzt mal.
Das machen die erstmal immer regelmäßig bei Video-Uploads.
Und das ist halt sehr unmotivierend, wenn man gerade wieder anfängt, nach drei bis vier Monaten, eine gute Idee hat, was hochlädt.
Und erstmal instant 200 D-Abos kriegt.
In den ersten zwei Stunden.
Wo du denkst so, hä?
Aber das ist irgendeine YouTube-Geschichte.
Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Ansonsten hat YouTube eigentlich ganz gut im Griff.
Aber trotzdem, ich müsste tatsächlich mal wieder was hochladen.
Es gibt auch, wie gesagt, ich habe auch eine richtig lange Themenliste.
Ich wollte ja zu diesem Emulations-Ding was machen.
Aber ich glaube, da nehme ich selbst nochmal was auf.
Ein bisschen strukturierter.
Weil das ist ein Thema, wo ich denke, das interessiert viele.
Okay, wir gucken uns erstmal das Video fertig an.
Influencer-Werbung.
Das ist halt das, wie sagt man, das Zündlein an der Waage.
Das ist, glaube ich, das richtige Stichwort.
Und deswegen wollte ich ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen, wo man wirklich sagen kann, ey, ihr habt nur aufs Geld geschaut.
Und das war bei Hydripe so.
Denn hier drin war keine Anti-Aging-Creme, so wie angepriesen, sondern einfach nur...
Aber mit diesem Holzdeckel sieht es auch schon so schön öko aus.
Das passt irgendwie aktuell.
Das heißt, die Influencerinnen und Influencer, die ich da mit reinlegen wollte, haben sich im Zweifel Gleitgel ins Gesicht geschmiert.
Das war damals dann Inissa Bukvic, die Freundin von Simon Desue.
Wo ich jetzt übrigens...
Wait a minute.
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Sind die nicht alle nach Dubai ausgewandert?
Oder nach Katar?
Oder nach... frag mich nicht.
Sind die da eigentlich noch?
Oder sind die alle wieder da?
Ich muss mal...
Wir gucken uns kein Video an.
Keine Sorge.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den Typ schreibt.
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
4,2 Millionen...
Ne, okay, vor zwei Jahren.
Den gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr.
Aber gut, der hat genug Kohle gemacht.
Ihr habt gesehen, dass RTL Plus eine Sendung mit ihr macht.
Und zwar Dubai Diaries.
Das tolle Leben in Dubai.
Wir zeigen es euch.
Das muss ja ganz besonders toll sein.
Ich meine, es ist ja der Traum von fast jedem Influencer, nach Dubai auszuwandern.
Seine Seele zu verkaufen und nichts Kritisches mehr über Dubai zu sagen.
Dementsprechend bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt.
Sie habe ich damals reingelegt.
Sie hat dafür Werbung gemacht.
Hat sogar ein Vorher-Nachher-Foto.
Das können wir an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal einblenden.
Gefaked.
Um halt die Leute zu überzeugen, dass diese Creme der Shit schlechthin ist und...
Ähm, er hat das Foto vergessen, oder?
Er hat die Quelle eingeblendet, aber das Foto gab es nicht.
...wenn sie danach einen ordentlichen Shitstorm bekommt.
Da kommen wir auch schon zu einer Thematik, die mir dann auch vorgehalten wurde.
Die ich so aber gar nicht beachtet habe.
Denn es sollte natürlich nicht der Aufruf sein, um jetzt eine Inissa Bukvic oder eine Vanessa Mariposa,
die später auch noch drauf reingefallen ist,
dafür zu mobben, zu...
Warum nicht?
...zu beleidigen oder sogar Morddrohungen auszuschließen.
Na gut, Morddrohungen ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel.
...wollte ich natürlich nicht.
Ich finde, dass Kritik auch bei Social Media völlig gerechtfertigt ist
und dass man sachlich in den Kommentaren kritisieren kann.
Aber alles darüber hinaus sollte auf jeden Fall nicht sein.
Vanessa Mariposa ist das nächste Stichwort...
Ja, sich ein bisschen drüber lustig machen kann man doch.
Ja.
Weil Morddrohungen ist natürlich was ganz anderes.
Ein bisschen drüber lustig machen...
Ich mein...
Warum nicht?
...hätte die darauf reingefallen ist und sogar sich noch eine schöne Geschichte überlegt hatte,
wo sie denn diese Creme angeblich im Biomarkt entdeckt hat.
Nämlich bei ihrer Mama in Salzburg.
Da wollte ich euch noch ein Produkt zeigen, was ich letztens bei meiner Mutter...
Alter, wenn ich die Instagram-Influencer alle schon sehe.
Boah, meine Güte.
...in Salzburg entdeckt habe.
Wenn ihr diesen Satz genauso mit Gänsehaut sagen könnt wie ich,
dann schreibt doch jetzt gerne mal lieben Gruß an die Mama aus Salzburg in die Kommentare.
Würde ich mich sehr, sehr freuen.
Die beiden habe ich erst mal reingelegt mit HydroHype,
habe gezeigt, ey, sobald Geld im Spiel ist,
sagen manche Influencer einfach nicht mehr die Wahrheit
und versuchen euch zu veräppeln.
Dann kam ja noch der dritte Kandidat ins Spiel...
Ja gut.
Das ist in...
Sag mal so, das ist in der Werbung eigentlich normal,
dass das...
Sag mal, du darfst ja in der Werbung nicht wirklich...
Also dir darf jetzt keiner was anpreisen,
was das Produkt nicht hat.
Also du kannst jetzt kein Auto mit zwei Türen verkaufen
und sagen, es hat vier Türen.
Du kannst das aber geschickt umschreiben.
Also was du sagen darfst,
ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein Anwalt,
aber du kannst zum Beispiel
ein super kleines Auto verkaufen
und sagen, geräumiger Innenraum und sowas.
Das ist so...
Was du nicht sagen darfst, ist 100 Quadratmeter.
Aber das ist ja falsch.
Aber wenn du sagst, geräumiger Innenraum,
das ist so, wie wenn es Wohnungen gibt,
so Wohnungen in bester Lage und sowas.
Ja gut, bester Lage, so nebenan irgendeiner Kreuzung
oder nebenan einer Bahnschiene oder sonst irgendwas.
Das ist natürlich sehr dehnbar, was das bedeuten kann.
Niemand geringeres als Leon Machère.
Den wollte ich damals ja auch mit Hydrohype reinlegen
und er hat dann den Spieß umgedreht.
Denn während meiner Produktion für Hydrohype
hat sich der Spieß so ein bisschen gedreht,
als ich nämlich gedacht habe,
ich werde von einer Großfamilie,
von der ich nie was gehört habe, nämlich El Agno bedroht.
Ich habe das damals tatsächlich ernst genommen,
weil es auch ernst drübergebracht wurde
vom angeblichen Manager von Leon
und habe mich auch, sage ich mal, in Kreisen umgehört,
ob man denn von dieser Familie was gehört hat.
Niemand hat davon was gehört und am Ende kam raus,
Leon hat uns alle Hops genommen.
Das kann ich heute genauso sagen.
Er hat uns mit dieser Aktion sehr, sehr Hops genommen.
Nicht nur mich, sondern auch die Reaction-Szene.
Und da muss man wirklich sagen, Chapeau an der Stelle.
Schade, dass er es noch mal irgendwie geschafft hat,
so einen überkrassen Prank zu machen,
weil da hat er wirklich mal gezeigt,
was man auf die Beine stellen kann,
wenn man sich darauf fokussiert, wenn man es ernst meint
und keinen Fake-Prank macht.
Muss ich wirklich sagen, hat mir damals echt gut gefallen,
auch wenn ich in diesem Fall das Opfer war.
Bei den anderen beiden sah die Rechtfertigung
ganz, ganz unterschiedlich aus. Bei Vanessa Mariposa
war es dann so, dass sie gesagt hat,
es tut ihr mega leid.
Oh nein, Entschuldigungsvideo.
Das ist ja mittlerweile schon der Standard, oder?
Also ich glaube, es gibt keinen größeren Influencer,
der nicht mindestens, also Instagram
und sowas in der Richtung,
die nicht schon irgendwelche heulenden
Entschuldigungsvideos gemacht haben.
Das gehört doch eigentlich
zum guten Ton mittlerweile.
Dass du dich vor die Kamera stellst,
irgendwie erzählst, wie furchtbar leid
dir das tut, am besten noch anfängst
oder wenn du nicht wirklich gerade heulen musst,
wenn du da zumindest so aussiehst,
als hast du gerade geheult
und dann erstmal dich wahnsinnig
für alles entschuldigst,
aber diese Entschuldigungsvideos
sind teilweise übelst geil.
Die Leute sitzen dann da
und ihnen tut das alles so wahnsinnig leid
und es ist alles so schrecklich
und sonst was,
aber zwischen den Zeilen sagen sie ihnen,
also viele Entschuldigungsvideos sind so,
sagen sie, eigentlich ist ja
gar nichts schlimmes passiert und habe ich auch nichts
verkehrt gemacht. Aber es tut mir so leid,
und ich muss jetzt heulen.
Sie möchte das nie wieder
so machen und sie bereut es
und es war auf jeden Fall eine Notlüge
und wird nicht mehr vorkommen.
Habe ich ihr auch ein Jahr lang geglaubt,
bis dann mein nächstes Projekt A Hole kam
und sie es wieder gemacht hat. Wer das nicht gesehen hat,
gern mal abchecken. Und bei Enissa war es tatsächlich so,
dass sie ein ellenlanges Statement
verfasst hat, wo sie gesagt hat, ey,
es gibt so viele Gründe, warum das so gelaufen ist.
Erstens, Marvin Wildhage hat darauf bestanden,
dass ich mir das Zeug ins Gesicht schmiere
und ich auch ein Vorher-Nachher-Foto mache.
Ich habe das Vorher-Nachher-Foto nicht bearbeitet.
Ich habe nur das Licht anders gemacht,
damit man irgendwie einen Unterschied sieht.
Naja, sie hätte auch einfach sagen können,
wenn ihr das wirklich gar nicht zusagt,
hätte sie auch einfach sagen können,
nee, mach ich nicht.
Du kennst ja die Bedingungen,
wenn du es unterschreibst.
Also,
die Auftraggeber,
denen steht
relativ frei,
was sie in Auftrag geben,
aber als Influencer
steht es dir genauso frei,
entweder zu sagen,
ich nehme es gar nicht an,
oder unter diesen Bedingungen,
oder die sind diese Punkte.
Das habe ich persönlich auch schon gemacht,
dass irgendwelche Anfragen gekommen sind,
da kriegst du ja meistens so ein 5-Seiten-PDF-Briefing
mit allen möglichen
Dingern dabei, sonst wie.
Und da habe ich auch schon gesagt,
so ein paar Punkte, also,
das und das, muss ich mal überlegen,
mir fällt jetzt gerade nichts ein,
nichts, was ich sagen würde.
Am besten sind immer noch die Briefings,
da muss ich ja immer kecken,
am besten sind diese Briefings,
die dir dann erzählen,
ja,
dieses, was weiß ich,
wenn es um irgendein Mobile-Game
oder irgendein Billig-Pay-to-Win-Game geht,
so, bestes Game im XY-Ranking,
super Reviews,
irgendwie
alle sind begeistert von diesem,
und da wird dann immer verwiesen auf Seiten
und Rankings,
von denen ich im Leben
noch nichts gehört habe.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
so ein bisschen wie die ganzen
Versicherungen und sonst was in Deutschland
und Supermärkte und so,
alle zeigen sich, wir sind wieder Testsieger,
wir haben in der Verbraucherumfrage
gewonnen, und dann guckst du da nach,
aha, ok, ok, wo denn, wo denn,
und dann stellst du fest, ah, ok,
in irgendeiner Zeitschrift, die von euch gesponsert wird,
alles klar, da habt ihr gewonnen,
ja, ganz toll,
aber wie gesagt, es steht einem ja frei,
den Bedingungen zuzustimmen oder nicht,
das heißt, da muss man sich im Nachhinein
nicht beschweren,
dass die so böse waren,
auf irgendwas bestanden haben,
also wenn zu mir jemand sagt,
hey Max, wir würden gerne, dass du
unsere neue Maus vorstellst,
aber,
keine Ahnung,
du sollst sagen, wie
super weich sich die Oberfläche
anfühlt, ja,
und die Oberfläche ist rau,
ich kann den Leuten noch keinen Mist erzählen,
kannst du sagen, ja gut, das können wir so nicht sagen,
du weißt es ja vorher,
und am besten ist immer, wenn sie dir dann ein
Script schicken, da muss ich
auch immer cringen,
also manchmal ist es so,
die schicken dir einfach nur ein,
ähm,
die schicken dir einfach nur so
ein Briefing, da steht dann drinnen,
ja, bestes Game ever, und du kannst dir
ein paar Punkte raussuchen, und gut ist, so,
da kannst du was zu sagen,
meistens wollen die das Video
vorher sehen, was ich aber auch vollkommen okay finde,
dass du nicht da irgendwas hinrotzt, was ihnen überhaupt
nicht gefällt, okay, so,
und dann hast du welche, die sind super
spezifisch, und
schreiben dir sogar ein Script,
und
ich müsste, ich müsste das echt mal raussuchen,
die Genshin Impact, Leute,
die haben mir, die haben mir
ein Script geschickt, Leute,
das war ein, das war ein
Sponsoring, glaube ich, für 60 Sekunden,
und die haben mir ein Script geschickt von
über einer A4-Seite,
für 60 Sekunden,
ich weiß
nicht, wie die sich das vorstellen,
wie das, wie das
funktionieren soll,
und ich hab das schon runter
gerattert as fuck, und da haben
immer noch Sachen gefehlt raus,
ja, die waren aber irgendwie der Meinung,
okay, das, das muss in die
60 Sekunden rein,
oder die 90 Sekunden waren es, glaube ich, 90
Sekunden, und es war nicht machbar, es war
absolut nicht machbar, ich hab dann einfach ein
paar Sachen übersprungen,
und es hat im Endeffekt keinen interessiert, aber
das war
schon weird, Champ, die haben wirklich,
die hatten ein super detailliertes Skript,
das war über eine A4-Seite lang,
einfach
zweifache Geschwindigkeit, wartet mal,
wartet mal, wer es nicht kennt,
ich war noch nie in einer Wüste,
welches,
in welches Video war das mit meinem
Genshin Sponsoring,
Moment, mal kurz
gucken,
Genshin, ah, hier,
hier, hier, hallo Leute, hier ist der Max,
wer es nicht kennt, wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
kaputt lachen müssen, Sponsoring, okay,
ach dann, mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt,
beziehungsweise das Game hätte Potenzial gehabt,
und für wen es sich lohnt, wieder reinzugucken,
und vielleicht, wer sich das
Ganze doch, Sponsoring
Time
verkaufen sollte, das erzähle ich euch gleich,
und das bringt mich auch zum Partner
des heutigen Videos, Genshin Impact ist ein
Open-World-Adventure-Game mit einer großen Anzahl
verschiedener Charaktere im Anime-Style,
und schneller geht's nicht mehr, oder?
Genshin Impact ist für PS5,
PS4, PC, auch für Mobilgeräte,
IOS und Android erhältlich,
die große, atmosphärische, offene Welt, ledig ein,
tiefer zu erforschen, eine Welt voller Geheimnisse,
in der es...
Ich muss diese A4-Seite
irgendwie vorlesen,
1,30,
in eineinhalb Minuten,
90 Sekunden, in 90 Sekunden
musste ich das irgendwie vorlesen,
7 Regionen, 7 Götter,
und wie könnte es anders sein, auch 7 Elemente
gibt, die kombiniert werden können, um neue Synergien
zu schaffen und noch mehr coole Angriffe auszuführen.
Die geschlossene Karte von Genshin,
wenn man nur Mondstadt, Leo, Sumero
mitzählt, ist mehr als 5 Millionen...
Ich hab absolut keinen Plan, wovon ich rede!
... 200 Fußballfelder in der realen
Welt. Das Spiel hat regelmäßige
Inhaltsupdates wie den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch
3.1, der neue aufregende
Region wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüsten-
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste!
Das ist doch schlecht, Max!
Das wollten die, dass ich das
1 zu 1 sage!
Ich sollte sagen, ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste!
Also hab ich halt
gesagt, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste!
... Region wie Sumero
mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt. Ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die Geheimnis-
Das ist so schlecht,
Alter!
... aufregende Region wie Sumero
mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt. Ich war
noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die
geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen
in Sumero erkunden. Und es gibt 3-
Das ist so schlecht!
... neue Helden im Spiel.
Sino, ein 5-Sterne-Elektro.
Canons, ein 4-Sterne-Heil-
Ich muss mich immer wegpissen, wenn ich
mein eigenes Sponsoring höre!
Das ist so schlecht, Alter!
...
was gesagt hat dass sie geflunkert hat also ist ja nichts anderes als ein
beweis dafür ich spreche ja nicht so gut deutsch
deswegen kann ich nur die hälfte davon verstehen also ich fand um ehrlich zu
sein und das jetzt mal völlig neutral ich fand es einfach an den haaren
herbeigezogen und fand es waren einfach faule ausreden für ein ja wer hätte das
gedacht instagram influencer bringen faule ausreden da wer hätte wer hätte
damit wer hätte da das hätte ich nie mit gerechnet
schwamm drüber das internet ist ja leider vergesslich und ja es werden
weiter fleißig werbungen gemacht für sachen die nicht so cool sind
dementsprechend konnte ich leider auch mit das internet das internet ist ja
gar nicht ich weiß was er macht aber muss man sagen dass das eigentlich das
gegenteil der fall das internet ist nicht vergesslich die leute sind
vergesslich und du findest im internet alles wieder also wenn er wenn einer in
20 jahren nach hydro halb sucht dann kann er sich das angucken kann sich
denken was haben die leute in 2020 da getrieben so viel auf der influenza
seite bewirken denn es werden weiterhin leuchten
zahnstunden beworben die nachweislich nicht funktioniert wird weiterhin
werbung für alle möglichen scheiß gemacht ich bin froh dass ich auf der anderen
seite der medaille was bewirken konnte denn ich habe das gefühl dass seit
hydro halb und dann auch noch mal durch die zuschauer ist es nicht also er
schreibt diese info ist doch teilweise schon sind wenn ich also wenn sie so
akzeptiert das ist die frage was sie vorhaben und du weißt doch gar nicht wie
das angekommen ist es ist durchaus möglich dass viele leute es down gelotet
haben gerade weil das sponsoring irgendwo noch besser gepasst hat bei
mir das kann man also das ist als super ich nicht mal groß durch bin auch
akkor komplexes feld auf sich war es lohnt oder nicht das kann man so
pauschal gar nicht sagen du kannst die befestigte werbung machen
für irgendwas die wirklich so so schlecht ist dass alle gringe und es
kann super erfolgreich sein das ist immer davon abhängig was man eigentlich
erreichen will
Und es ist ein super komplexes Themengebiet.
Ey, das glaube ich nicht, dass die Leute da, also bei mir nicht, ja, bei mir nicht.
Also die Leute werden das bei mir nicht geglaubt haben.
Aber ich weiß, dass sich trotzdem einige runtergeladen haben.
Ich habe keine Statistik am Ende bekommen, aber so sehr interessiert es mich auch nicht.
Zuschauer einfach kritischer mit Werbung umgehen und einfach auch nochmal hinterfragen,
wenn das Wort Werbung in irgendeiner Ecke steht.
Wobei man muss auch sagen, viele hochkarätige, jahrelange etablierte Influencer
schaffen es immer noch nicht, ihre Werbung vernünftig zu markieren.
Ja, das finde ich auch verwerflich.
Das ist das, womit ich dann tatsächlich, was ich als problematisch empfinde.
Wenn das nicht markiert ist als Werbung.
Also mir reicht es ja schon.
Am besten ist natürlich, wenn oben so ein Werbeblock.
Mir reicht es auch theoretisch schon, wenn es in der Beschreibung steht.
Oder aber wenn einer sagt,
ähm,
dieses Video,
dieses Video ist unterstützt von XY oder das folgende wurde mir zur Verfügung.
Es muss in irgendeiner Art und Weise kenntlich sein.
Am besten ist natürlich oben in der Ecke, ja, eine Einblendung.
Aber das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig sein.
Finde ich persönlich am besten.
Aber so gar nichts erwähnen und noch zusätzlich es zu verschleiern
und so zu tun, als hat man das Produkt zufällig im Aldi gefunden,
das ist natürlich problematisch.
Finde ich auch sehr, sehr ärgerlich.
Könnte man ja auch mal überlegen, ein Projekt drüber zu machen.
Egal.
Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist,
dass die Leute, die meine Videos schauen,
einfach jetzt, sag ich mal, geschulter sind
und gewiefter an die Sache rangehen
und sich nicht von vorne und hinten was vom Pferd erzählen lassen.
Und das merke ich vor allem in den Situationen,
die mir persönlich nahegehen,
wo ich wirklich stolz bin,
wo, was ein Ritterschlag...
Kommt, kommt in dem Video noch irgendwas dazu?
Nee, oder?
Können wir noch, können wir noch komplett, komplett skippen?
Nee.
Eigentlich kommt dazu gar nichts Spannendes mehr.
Hier ist der Chat auch pfeifett.
Ja, das stimmt.
Der Chat ist...
Extrem pfeifett.
High IQ Chat.
Nur hier.
Moin.
Battlefield Update 3.2...
Moment, wirklich?
Ist das schon Season 4?
Nee?
Nee, doch, doch, oder?
Nee.
Ja, was denn nun?
Es ist nicht Season 4.
Nee, es ist 3.
Ach, 3 ist noch Season 3.
Okay.
First Major Game Update 2023.
Bla, bla, bla.
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Ihr returnt gar nicht wirklich zum Klassensystem.
Ihr behaltet das Specialist-System nur,
dass es ein paar Einschränkungen gibt,
wer was nehmen kann.
Und ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen,
das wird richtiger Abfuck.
Die Fahrzeuge sind in Battlefield 2042
zum größten Teil absolut Crap.
Bis auf ein paar Helis, die jetzt schon mega krass sind.
Und jetzt meint ihr, was passiert,
wenn die beliebtesten Specialists nicht Heli geiern können?
Dann gibt's noch mehr auf den Sack.
Von Helis.
Also, da bin ich mal echt gespannt, ob das...
Oh, Breakaway.
Okay, die Map hat's auch wirklich nötig.
Die Map ergibt danach dann zwar überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr,
weil die Ölbohrstation quasi in der Küste steckt.
Aber okay, das kann ja alles sein.
Exclusive Rewards kriegen wir, Leute.
Das wird was.
Das wird was, Leute.
Ein Buff für Helis.
Und das nicht mehr jeder,
der Anti-Air nehmen kann.
Na, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Aber wie gesagt, es ändert sich ja gar nicht so grundlegend was.
Die Specialists, nur das bleibt alles da.
Das Einzige, was passiert ist,
dass jeder Specialist,
der ja eigentlich jetzt schon eine Kategorie hat,
es wird ein bisschen umsortiert,
dann Gadget-Beschränkungen kriegt.
Also du kannst da nicht mehr
Anti-Tank-Sachen
als Assault mitnehmen und sowas.
Bist du nicht bei EA Creator Network?
Das kannst du vergessen.
Die laden mich nie wieder zu irgendwas ein.
Never.
Die laden mich nie wieder ein.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Versuchen?
Nee.
Ich versuch das auch gar nicht.
Dafür interessiert es mich nicht mehr genug.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich hab Sponsoring damals angenommen
zu Battlefield 2042.
Ich hab auch die drei Videos dafür produziert.
Und zwischendurch
habe ich halt ein, zwei Videos hochgeladen,
wo ich sage, was Sache ist mit dem Game.
Und ich glaube,
seitdem laden die mich nie wieder ein.
Ist mir aber auch scheißegal, ehrlich gesagt.
Kann ich Spiele mir auch so angucken.
Ich brauch kein Sponsoring
und irgendwelches Early Access und sonst was.
Okay, also ich kann
meine Lieblings-
meine Lieblings-Kombi
kann ich nach wie vor spielen.
McKay MediPen.
Alles gut.
Gadgets.
Ah nee,
kann ich nicht.
Ich hab, ich hab immer,
ich hab immer MediPen
und Motion Sensor gespielt.
Das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist auch, ist auch okay so.
Repair, repaired.
Dass ich es insgesamt besser spiele,
glaube ich dir sogar.
Das ist ja nicht mehr so viel Spam vomgleichen.
Gut, Repair Tool.
Seriously, irgendjemand hat,
hat das Spiel irgendwer mal gespielt
und wurde repariert im Fahrzeug.
Ich glaube, ich wurde nicht einmal
im, in, in irgendeinem Fahrzeug repariert
in diesem Spiel.
Recon gibt's ganze, ganze zwei.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wir probieren das aus.
Wir probieren das aus.
So, wann, wann gibt's denn?
Wann kommt denn das raus?
Gibt's da schon Release, Release Date?
Release Date?
Am zwanz-
Äh, nicht so ganz.
Players can expect update-
Okay, also gibt ja,
wenn's noch Januar kommen soll,
gibt's ja nicht so viele,
so viele Möglichkeiten.
Okay, alles klar.
Jep, das gucken wir uns nächste Woche mal an.
Da muss ich, da muss ich erst mal den Kram wieder,
da muss ich mir auf dem neuen Rechner
wahrscheinlich die EA-App installieren
oder irgend so'n Crap.
Dann können wir mal gucken,
wie gut das auf dem neuen Rechner läuft.
Dann haben wir mal den direkten Vergleich.
13.900k, 40, 90 versus 8.700k, 1.080 TI.
Sollte, sollte schon ein bisschen besser laufen.
Okay, was können wir uns, was können wir uns anschauen?
Zeig ich mal her.
I've tested, okay.
Lass, lass mal durchgucken, ob das Video was taugt.
Ich hab von dem noch nie was geguckt.
13 Millionen, 13 Millionen Subscriber.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eher was, keine Ahnung.
Ey, so eine hatte ich auch mal.
Erinner, erinnert sich noch einer an das Video?
Erinnert sich noch einer an mein Video?
Moment.
Max FPS Zahnbürste.
Wo ist denn das Video hin?
Da ist es doch.
Die Pro Gamer Zahnbürste.
Ich hatte auch mal so ein Teil.
Mit, mit, mit Bluetooth.
Alter.
Ich bin im falschen Browser.
Deswegen.
Okay, 5000 Gadgets.
Mal gucken, ob das Video was taugt.
Ich, ich glaube, ich glaube eher nicht.
Aber mal, mal gucken.
I've been reviewing gadgets for the last 12 years of my life.
Over a thousand videos.
5,000 products.
But these are the 10 that I actually use every single day of my life.
Each one more essential than the last.
And number 10 is my smart trash can.
Das ist, das ist auch so ein Ding, was in, was in YouTube Videos so aktuell.
Es darf kein Bild sein, wo sich nicht irgendwas bewegt.
It sits permanently just outside our filming room.
And I picked it because it is the most streamlined way to trash things.
I can literally wave my hand over it and it will open.
Essentiell. Ganz wichtig.
If you don't have a hand to spare, you can actually just say, open can.
And you can just.
Okay.
Naja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Übrigens.
Für die meisten.
Für den meisten Müll.
Braucht man überhaupt keinen Deckel.
Nur mal so.
Der einzige Mülleimer, der einen Deckel braucht, ist Biomüll.
Du brauchst für Plastikmüll.
Keinen Deckel.
Du brauchst für Papiermüll.
So habe ich das übrigens auch.
Ich habe hier so zwei kleine Tonnen stehen.
Ja, Restmüll, Biomüll.
Dafür brauchst du einen Deckel.
Also ich habe hier für Papier und Plastik.
Ich habe so zwei kleine Tonnen.
Das sind ja keine Tonnen.
Das sind eher so Trage.
Ich glaube ursprünglich waren das irgendwelche Wäsche.
Wäschetragedinger.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe hier zwei kleine Plastiktonnen stehen.
Eines für Papier und eins für Plastik.
Die haben keinen Deckel.
Wozu brauchen die einen Deckel?
Da stinkt ja nichts von.
Das wäre mir viel zu umständlich, wenn ich ein bisschen Papier wegschmeißen müsste.
Erstmal die Hand über den Mülleimer zu waven.
Oder zu sagen.
Mülleimer geh auf.
Am besten noch.
Rein über proprietäre Cloud meinen Mülleimer steuern.
Ja.
Und das schöne an meinen zwei Tonnen ist.
Da passt auch einiges rein.
Und ohne das ich das vorher irgendwie klein krempeln muss.
Das wird einfach genommen.
Also ich könnte jetzt von hier zum Beispiel.
Machen wir das mal.
Hier.
Ich weiß nicht ob ihr das hört.
Ich nehme jetzt mal was.
So hier zack.
Und jetzt könnte ich einfach so.
Achtung Leute.
Weiß nicht ob man es gehört hat.
Und schon liegt es im Müll.
Oder hat nur das halbe Zimmer gepfeffert.
Das trifft man auch vom Schreibtisch aus.
Naja gut.
Weiter.
Wisst ihr was auch schön Anti Fingerprint ist?
Plastik.
What?
Naja.
Okay.
Nice to have.
Alles klar. Aber ansonsten.
Kannst du was empfehlen?
Ne.
Also MW2 ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Warzone 2 ist auch überhaupt nicht meins.
Das letzte Battlefield ist auch verkackt.
Nope.
Das die zwei Sachen kannst du.
Wenn du dir Spaß an den alten Teilen hattest.
Eigentlich nahezu vergessen.
Death Operator danke für den Sub.
Ansonsten. Du kannst die alten Teile spielen.
Ja das geht immer noch.
Tja ne ansonsten kann ich dir leider nichts empfehlen.
Wie kommst du mit Windows 11 zurecht?
Gezwungenermaßen muss ich mit Windows 11 zurecht kommen.
Großen Bock habe ich nicht drauf.
Ich meine ich war schon nicht sonderlich scharf drauf.
Ähm.
Auf die Windows 10 Bedienung.
Aber Windows 11 hat noch ein paar Sachen oben drauf gesetzt.
Zum Beispiel.
Das ich diesen Platz in meiner Taskleiste
nicht sinnvoll benutzen kann.
Für irgendwas.
Weil alle meine Fenster zwangsgruppiert sind.
Ich weiß nicht was sich Microsoft dabei gedacht hat.
Guck mal.
Was ist in meiner Taskleiste.
Und da ist einfach nichts.
Ja das könnte man machen.
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein.
Dass man daran.
Ja wahrscheinlich werde ich sowas auch mal machen.
Oder ich probiere mal irgendeinen Launcher aus.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein.
Das es so verkackt wird.
Hättest du auch mal Lust auf ein Singleplayer Game.
Klar wenn es wieder was gescheites gibt.
So erstmal Gadgets fertig gucken.
Was gibt es noch für Pongas Gadgets.
Achja.
Ok also es ist wirklich so.
Die Kamera darf in diesem Video
keine Sekunde still stehen.
Sonst schalten die Leute ab.
Leute meint ihr das ist wirklich sein Haus.
Oder das ist irgendeine Kulisse zum aufnehmen.
So wirklich.
So wirklich sicher kann man sich da ja nicht sein.
Das haben wir uns doch letztens angeguckt.
Wir haben uns doch letztens die Thermoskanne von denen angeguckt.
Und sind zu dem Schluss gekommen.
Das es absolut unsinniger Kram ist.
Wieso versuchst du nicht komplett auf Linux umzusteigen.
Dazu habe ich ein Video gemacht.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Da sage ich eigentlich alles was ich zu wir steigen einfach mal umdenke.
Kurz gesagt.
Was ist doch wahr.
Egal.
Kurz gesagt es gibt halt ein paar Sachen.
Wo ich dann wahrscheinlich nicht machen könnte.
Also gerade.
So was Gaming und Contentproduktion angeht.
mit der Software an die ich gewohnt bin.
Kannste vergessen unter Linux.
Du kriegs es vielleicht ein bisschen
gefrickel teilweise zum Laufen.
Aber wozu.
Die beste Kombination ist einfach Beides zu verwenden.
Ich verwende Linux für so ziemlich alles.
ich verwende Linux für so ziemlich alles.
Was auch nur entfernt mit Technik.
Und Basteln zu tun hat.
Und Windows für Gaming und Content.
Und matrices für Gaming und Content.
Und Streaming.
Sorry, sorry, GNU-Linux, wenn wir das nicht richtig sagen, ihr wisst, was passiert, wenn wir das nicht richtig sagen, dann ist er am Start, dann wird das Stream direkt GNU-Band, selbstverständlich ist es GNU-Linux.
Also, seriously, wenn ich meine Kaffeetasse-Firmware updaten muss, man könnte sagen, ich bin technikfeindlich, aber ich glaube, wer sich meine Streams anguckt, wird feststellen, es ist das Gegenteil der Fall, aber man muss nicht jeden Scheiß machen, der geht.
Ganz ehrlich, die Teetasse finde ich sogar noch ganz sinnvoll.
Diese Thermoskanne, die es von denen gegeben hat, die wir uns das letzte Mal angeguckt haben, die fand ich bescheuert.
Die Teetasse selbst, das leuchtet mir sogar noch ein, also das ist was, was ich sogar, dem ich mal sogar einen Try probieren geben würde.
Ich kann keinen deutschen Satz mehr normal bilden, gerade fällt mir ein, also was ich sogar mal ausprobieren würde, was kostet denn sowas?
Was ich einen Try geben würde, Alter, ich kann nicht mehr normal reden.
Embermark, what? Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Unter der Haube ist es doch im Endeffekt eine Platte, die wahrscheinlich per Induktion oder so den Boden von der Tasse heizt.
Das ist jetzt wieder der Punkt, wisst ihr?
Ich könnte mir das theoretisch kaufen, das ist kein Ding, also am Geld soll es da nicht scheitern, aber ich sehe es einfach nicht ein.
Ich sehe es nicht ein, 200 Euro dafür auszugeben.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Alternativdinger geblieben.
Genauso, genauso gut, ja.
Im Zweifelsfalle die Tasse eher schneller leer als kalt.
Mal gucken, wie viel da reinpasst.
Also ich habe hier so 0,7er, 0,7er Tassen, die sind relativ groß.
Da habe ich zum Beispiel jetzt auch gerade Tee drinne, was auch relativ lange hält, weil die Tasse so groß ist.
Wie viel passt denn da rein?
300 Milliliter?
Ey, okay, das ist, 300 Milliliter, das musst du doch nicht, das musst du doch nicht warm, warm halten.
Was? 14 Fluidouts?
Hell yeah, Freedom Unit.
Okay, was sind, was sind 14 Fluidouts in Milliliter?
414 Milliliter, alles klar.
Okay, also es passt ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte rein.
Also wenn ich meine 0,7er, 0,7er, das ist ein großer, großer Becher hier.
Also wenn ich diesen 0,7er Becher quasi so...
zu, so über die Hälfte voll mache, dann ist, naja, ganz ehrlich, das musst du gar nicht lange wärmen,
weil das wahrscheinlich in einer halben Stunde eh leer getrunken ist.
Naja, okay, nee, ich glaube, das probiere ich nicht aus.
Okay.
Okay, wenn man eineinhalb Stunden braucht für 400 Milliliter,
dann macht's, macht's vielleicht Sinn.
Okay, this one is unexpectedly awesome.
So, about two years ago, I made the decision to start prioritizing my mouth care routine.
So, I got myself a water flosser, which clears the bits of food in between my teeth,
and then upgraded my manual tooth.
Was ist das?
Spritzt das Wasser im Mund rum, oder wie?
Also quasi ein Hochdruckreiniger für die Zähne, sozusagen.
Ja.
Weiß nicht, ob das was bringt.
Könnte, achso, da geht's gar nicht drum.
There's an LED color display on it, for starters.
It's there, so you can cycle through the seven different cleaning modes.
You don't actually need seven different cleaning modes, but I do use a combination of daily clean,
tongue cleaning mode, which has actually made a big difference.
Zungenreinigung.
To making my breath just feel fresh all the time.
And then whitening mode for...
Macht das Sinn?
Bringt das irgendwas?
Zungenreinigung?
Also ein extra Zungenreinigungs-Mode.
Wenn man etwas hängen hat, kann man ja auch die normale Bürste nehmen, also braucht man einen extra Zungenreinigungs-Modus.
Zungenreinigungs-Modus.
Aha.
Okay, das hat meine, also meine Zahnbürste hat das auch, die vibriert dann leicht, wenn ich zu hart drücke, Gachi-Bass.
Wie, hat das auch eine Smartphone-App, die nur über die China-Chinesen-Cloud geht?
Ah, okay.
Passt da nur ein Stück Brot rein?
Nee, oder? Da kriegst du schon zwei Stück nebeneinander rein.
Ja gut, den würde ich jetzt auch nicht mehr kaufen, sondern wenn überhaupt das neueste Modell.
Und ich muss dazu sagen, leider sind die nur noch sehr schwierig zu flashen, diese Dinger.
Und deswegen kommen sie für mich nicht mehr in Frage, obwohl ich gerne mal einen Staubsauger-Roboter ausprobieren würde,
der eine Entleerungsstation hat.
Das ist nämlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich auf meinen keinen Bock habe.
Ich habe nämlich noch einen Roborock S5 und der hat keine Ausleerstation.
Da muss man quasi laufend runter, runter kriechen zur Ladestation und das auswechseln und den rumdrehen und so.
Das ist halt doof.
Ja, die Dreamy-Geschichten kämen vielleicht auch noch in Frage.
Aber auch nur, weil man sie gescheit flashen kann.
Ja, die Dreamy-Geschichten kämen vielleicht auch noch in Frage, aber auch nur, weil man sie gescheit flashen kann.
Und die Dreamy-Geschichten kämen vielleicht auch noch in Frage, aber auch nur, weil man sie gescheit flashen kann.
Du wirst dir über einen längeren Zeitraum bemerken, dass es einige Obstacke gibt, die es nicht mag.
Wie dieser Rubber hier ist ein bisschen zu hoch, um ihn zu steigen.
Aber dann musst du einfach in die App gehen und es als No-Go-Zone einstellen.
Und es wird einfach alles anders machen.
Aber es ist auch literally halb der totalen Zeit, die wir in diesem Haus vakuumieren.
90% davon ist dein Problem.
Na gut.
Ich muss ja ehrlich sagen,
Wenn die Airpods die gleiche Form haben wie diese normalen iPhone-Kopfhörer,
dann sind meine Ohrmuscheln nicht gemacht für Apple-geformte Kopfhörer.
Dann sind meine Ohrmuscheln nicht gemacht für Apple-geformte Kopfhörer.
Und die können die Fliesen wischen und die können das Wasser wechseln, die ganz neuen.
Also Lappen hat meine auch, habe ich aber noch nie verwendet.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, selbst wenn ich einen hätte mit Station für Wasser und Lappen,
ich würde wahrscheinlich nur Teppichboden.
Also mal ganz einfach, ich habe hier auch nur Teppichboden.
Das einzige, wo ich halt Fliesen habe, ist im Bad und im Flur und unten im Bad und in der Küche.
Das sind keine Fliesen, da ist es halt glatt.
Aber da brauche ich keinen Staubsauger-Robot dafür.
Da kommt ja eh nicht die Treppe hoch und runter.
Was kostet ein neuer? Ah, ist relativ teuer.
Ich glaube 600-700 Euro muss man für die neuesten mit Absaugstationen sogar schon rechnen.
Wenn nicht sogar mehr. Das ist nicht billig.
Was ist eigentlich aus Beats geworden?
Die hat Apple ja auch gekauft.
Dr. Dre Beats.
By the way, ich mag auch keine Kopfhörer, die in ihr sind.
Die mit diesen Gummis, die sich so an die Ohren anlegen.
Das kann ich maximal eine halbe Stunde, Stunde anhaben.
Dann wird es unangenehm.
Ich habe viele Massagen versucht.
Und der Thera-Face ist momentan mein Nummer 1.
Und ein Sub zu dem Kanal wäre...
Könnte auch was anderes sein.
What the fuck?
TikTok.
You can use this on other areas. So, so.
Oh ja, Leute. Merkt ihr auch, was für krasse Tension ihr bei euch im Vorhead habt?
Also, mein Vorhead ist so tense.
Also, use it while you're watching a movie with other people.
And then the cherry on top is that it's also just a feel-good factor.
This thing is like an 18-1-Face-Treatment.
Like, the massage brings blood to your face and therefore reduces the appearance of lines.
It uses microcurrents to increase the muscle tone of your face.
Different types of LED to clear acne and reduce the bags under your eyes.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
The list goes on.
Ganz bestimmt bringen die LEDs da vorne irgendwas.
One of the key tools that allowed me to make sure I was getting enough water was the AirUp-Bottle,
which uses these scented capsules on top to trick your brain into thinking that you're drinking flavored water,
when you're not.
Well, since then I have upgraded to the AirUp-Steel, which uses the same...
What?
Jetzt bin ich...
Okay, man trinkt Wasser, was beim Trinken so schmeckt wie...
Wie...
Gezuckertes oder halt...
Tja...
Mit Geschmack?
Fuck yeah.
...interchangeable flavor system, but is also just a really premium bottle,
which keeps your cold drinks cold, doesn't discolor over time,
and doesn't at all change the flavor of the water, which some plastics can.
Now, how much you actually end up liking this product will vastly depend on the expectations you have going in.
Because if you buy one of these expecting it will be able to turn water into juice just by using scent,
you'll be sorely mistaken.
It's more like it gives the water a noticeable scent and then a slight...
Wie wär's...
By the way, wie wär's...
Wie wär's mit einfach Wasser trinken?
Ich...
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar nicht das Bedürfnis dafür, dass mein Wasser nach irgendwas schmeckt.
Wenn ich will, dass mein Wasser nach irgendwas schmeckt, ähm, trink ich Tee.
Das ist dann zwar kein Wasser mehr, aber das schmeckt nach was.
...taste, but I mean that's enough for me to reach for my bottle way more than I otherwise would have.
So, it's making a big difference to my life.
But...
Okay.
...even more essential to my day-to-day life...
...is my smartphone of choice.
Ja gut, das ist klar.
There are actually two that I use right now.
The main phone, which I carry everywhere and do all of my work-related things on, is the
iPhone 14 Pro Max.
It's not the most impressed I've ever been with an iPhone in that the battery life is
slightly weaker than last generation, the cameras pick up a lot of dust and they're kind of
hard to clean, and I've ended up turning off the always-on display, which was one of the
main new features that it launched with.
But having an iPhone as my backbone is also super convenient, because A the key way that
I talk to my girlfriend is via voice notes.
And they just sound so much better than they do on Android.
Oh, guess what?
You won't believe it.
The new Samsung phone is apparently going to come with a 200-megapixel camera.
That is so exciting, right?
Sure.
B both myself and a lot of the key people around me also use Apple products.
So, being able to FaceTime them has resulted in higher quality calls when we're trying
to coordinate the logistics of a holiday, for example.
And being able to just airdrop them the photos from our latest gathering is a genuine time-saving.
And see, as I'm starting to make more...
Wie gut, es ist ein iPhone.
Ich muss mir auch noch ein neues iPhone kaufen jetzt, weil ich wechsle ja den Arbeitgeber
zum 1.4.
Und das iPhone, was ich aktuell verwende, ist von der Firma gesponsert.
Das muss ich zurückgeben.
Ich bekomme wahrscheinlich ein neues Smartphone im neuen Job.
Wahrscheinlich auch ein iPhone, aber ich kaufe mir endlich mal ein eigenes, mit eigenem
Vertrag dabei, dass ich das hin und her nicht mehr hab.
...normal personal videos on my phone.
I find myself recording footage on my phone more than I ever used to.
For the simple fact that your smartphone is the most convenient camera that you're always
gonna have with you.
And so, for as long as the iPhone leads the pack when it comes to video, it's gonna be
really hard to switch away from that.
I've got the Casetify Bounce Case around it, which is not exactly streamlined, but does
give me extreme peace of mind that my phone is protected.
And there is also a tiny little heart that...
Das ist halt das Blöde an den Kameras, dass die überstehen, ne?
Du kannst das Handy nicht mehr flach auffangen.
Du kannst das Handy nicht mehr flach аффangen.
Ohne Case drumherum.
Und wenn du eh nen Case drumherum brauchst, stellst du halt komplett in Frage, warum du
denn den Kram am Anfang erst so dünn baust.
I've got the Casetify Bounce Case around it, which does give me extreme peace of mind,
that my phone is protected.
Aber dann benutze ich auch manchmal das Google Pixel 7 Pro.
Meistens wirklich für Fotos, weil ich finde, dass es schärfer, mehr cinematische Bilder
produziert.
Und dann natürlich das Foto-Editieren, weil nichts über die Intelligenz des Google-Editier-Suites
überreicht.
Also was ist Gadget Nummer 1?
Was ist der wichtigste Teil der Technik in meinem gesamten Leben?
Sein Smart-Klo.
Leute, ich call's jetzt.
Der hat auch ein Smart-Klo.
Der hat auch ein High-Tech-Klo.
Das ist das Beste.
Das ist ja lame.
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt irgendwas, irgendwas Spannendes.
Nah dran, ja.
Fast ein Klo.
Mein New Desktop.
Oh, der stellt uns ein i3 vor.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ein bisschen harte Kost.
Was ist das?
Was?
Ich habe 72 Stunden nur mit VR-Brille gearbeitet.
Okay, Zeit mal her.
72 Stunden nicht an meinem Computer.
Moment, ist das nicht?
Moment.
Das ist der Kerl, den wir letzte Woche auch schon geguckt haben.
Der, wartet mal, der hat doch, letzte Woche haben wir doch ein Video geguckt.
Da hat er seine Wohnung gezeigt, irgendwas wie meine super High-Tech-Wohnung oder sowas.
Und wo wir uns gefragt haben, wo genau ist jetzt eigentlich der High-Tech?
Naja, der Zug denkt sich das vielleicht.
Nee.
Nee, das ist nicht der mit der 5.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine.
Das mit der 5.000 Euro Kaffeemaschine, das war der Küchen, der Küchenplaner.
Und was die Nachteile.
Das ist die MetaQuest 2 für 350 Euro und das die MetaQuest Pro, die neue High-Tech-Brille
für 1.800 Euro.
Und der Unterschied zwischen den beiden, die ist jetzt, die ist jetzt rund, das ist schon
mal 700 Euro mehr wert.
Fiel schon beim ersten Tragen deutlich auf.
36% schärfere Displays.
Es sieht auch, es sieht auch ehrlich gesagt leichter und bequemer aus.
36% höherem Kontrast.
Das ist, als würde man HD mit Full-HD vergleichen.
Außerdem sind die Linsen schärfer und haben nicht mehr dieses komische Glühen um helle
Elemente herum.
Die Brille ist insgesamt weniger frontlastig und erkennt selbstständig, wie sie auf dem
Gesicht sitzt.
Sie zeigt an, was ich tun muss, um den Sitz zu optimieren.
Hier ein bisschen höher, da mal kurz drehen und fertig.
Das ist mir schon ein bisschen schwer.
Die Brille ist insgesamt weniger frontlastig und erkennt selbstständig, wie sie auf dem
Gesicht sitzt.
Sie zeigt an, was ich tun muss, um den Sitz zu optimieren.
Hier ein bisschen höher, da mal kurz drehen und fertig.
Das ist möglich, weil es Kameras gibt, die auf das Gesicht schauen.
Und das funktioniert so gut, dass ich einen virtuellen Avatar habe, der meine Mimik und
Gestik nachahmt.
Es liegen zwei Controller im Lieferumfang bei, aber die braucht man gar nicht.
Kameras erfassen die Hände, Arme und sogar Finger.
Und das alles passiert auf der Perspektive.
Das ist tatsächlich mal eine gute Neuerung.
... mit ihrem Snapdragon XR2 Plus Prozessor.
Für mein Experiment verbinde ich meinen normalen Computer kabellos mit der Meta Workspace App.
Und ich bediene alles ganz normal über Tastatur und Maus, die ich in der virtuellen Welt sehen kann,
weil ein Videofenster von der echten Welt ausgeschnitten wird.
Und ich sage euch, es ist wirklich skurril, diesen Übergang zwischen echten Händen und digitalen Händen zu erleben.
Jetzt, wo alles eingerichtet ist, beginnt Tag 1.
Bis zu drei Monitore schweben vor mir. Sie sind etwa 48 Zoll groß und haben eine...
Sag mal, das ruckelt alles, oder?
... voller De-Ausrüstung.
Ruckelt das alles? Das wirkt so ruckelig.
Ich kann Fenster hin- und herschieben, Musik über die Computer-Lautsprecher...
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich an der Kopfbewegung.
... oder die Lautsprecher der Brille selbst hören.
Letztere sind qualitativ so lala, aber für ein bisschen Videoschauen geht schon klar.
Cool finde ich, dass sich der Ton relativ zu meinen Kopfbewegungen mitbewegt.
Wenn ich von einem Video wegschaue, dann wandert auch der Ton weg.
Gewöhnliche Office-Aufgaben, wie Mails beantworten, Inhalte recherchieren, Dokumente bearbeiten...
Das alles funktioniert absolut problemlos und nach kurzer Eingewöhnung...
Ja, die Frage ist halt nur, wenn das problemlos funktioniert, was ist...
Also, warum sollte man es machen? Das funktioniert ohne Brille genauso problemlos.
... habe ich fast vergessen, dass es die Monitore gar nicht wirklich gibt.
Es fühlt sich alles so an wie sonst auch.
Ich kann relativ gut, aber nicht perfekt blind tippen.
Ich kann aber die Tastatur durch die 3D-Kameras der Brille sehen...
... oder ich kann am unteren Rand der Brille vorbeischauen und das hilft sehr.
Ich bearbeite also in der Meta-Quest das Video über die Meta-Quest, was ganz schön Meta ist.
Normalerweise sitze ich vor einem 6K-Monitor.
Dagegen ist Full-HD natürlich deutlich unschärfer, auch wenn ich Texte gut lesen kann.
Das Störenste sind für mich immer die kurzen Aussetzer und Hänger, die durch die WLAN-Verbindung entstehen.
Und auch...
Die Akkulaufzeit ist mit gerade mal zwei Stunden nicht sonderlich lang.
Das reicht natürlich.
Zwei Stunden ist nichts für den Arbeitstag.
Zwei Stunden ist gut, wenn du das zum Spielen verwendest, vielleicht ab und zu mal.
... um zwei Stunden zu arbeiten, aber dann muss man es neu aufladen.
Das hat jetzt in meinem Fall so eineinhalb Stunden gedauert.
Man kann die Brille aber auch durchgängig mit dem PC einstecken und durchgängig am Strom benutzen.
Und ich denke, so werde ich das in Zukunft machen.
Ja, das ist dann besser.
Dieser Streifen auf der Stirn, das ist...
Der dauert auch eine Weile, bis der wieder weg ist.
Anders als die meisten anderen VR-Projekte...
Ja, das ist dann besser.
... VR-Brillen ist die...
Da bräuchte er jetzt diesen Face-Entspanner aus dem letzten Video, dann wäre der rote
Streifen ratzfatz wieder weg.
... Quest Pro zu den Seiten und nach unten hin offen.
Das mochte ich mehr als erst gedacht.
Relaged Smith, dankeschön für den Zap.
Man fühlt sich weniger eingeschlossen, falls das irgendwie Sinn macht.
Man kann aber auch magnetische Cover dranmachen, um das Licht komplett wegzublocken.
Und für Gaming macht das schon Sinn.
Als Belohnung spiele ich etwas Minigolf.
Und ich spiele sogar so schlecht wie in echt.
Krass.
Das ist super friedlich gerade.
Ja.
Weil du so viel gearbeitet hast.
Und du bist...
Jawoll, Minigolf.
Jetzt fühlt es sich an wie eine ganz andere Welt, weil jetzt sitzt du nicht mehr am Schreibtisch
und hast da dein Computer, sondern du bist hier im Minigolf, du hast ein bisschen Aussicht,
du schaust in die Ferne, es ist super friedlich.
Ist schon irgendwie cool.
Sieht halt einfach mal aus wie ein Wii-Spiel.
Superhot.
Wow.
Wo wird geschossen?
Da, da.
Das Spiel ist aber auch irgendwo wie gemacht für VR.
Mir hat auch das Gefühl, man verbrennt auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Das Gefühl, man verbrennt auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Kalorien als bei jeder anderen
Konsole.
Und zu guter Letzt Among Us in 3D.
Es ist ein ganz ruhiges Spiel, aber es ist sehr spannend.
Suß.
Und es ist sehr witzig in dieser Spielwelt drin zu sein, die man normalerweise nur von
oben kennt.
Das hier ist die erste virtuelle Sponsor-Ankündigung jemals, denn dieses Video wurde unterstützt
durch RhinoShield.
Und auch wenn ich hier in der virtuellen Realität kein Smartphone habe, kann es mir in meiner
echten Realität halt immer noch runterfallen.
Und RhinoShield-Höhlen bieten den besten Schutz.
Es gibt viele coole, modulare Designs.
Alles klar.
Und für das iPhone sogar extrem krassen MagSafe-Support.
Ob er auch schon mal in einer Wüste war?
Mit diesem Rabattcode bekommt ihr 10% Rabatt auf das gesamte Sortiment von RhinoShield.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr solche verrückten Ideen überhaupt erst möglich macht.
Oh nein.
Kommt der Mann her?
Ja, sie ist gerade ausgegangen.
Der Akku ist leer.
Ich schätze mal, das war's für heute.
Der Tag hat sich insgesamt sehr gut gemacht.
Der Tag hat sich insgesamt ein bisschen diffuser, aber auch kürzer angefühlt als
sonst.
Ich hatte nicht so ein richtiges Verhältnis zur Zeit.
Ich habe auch nicht so richtig mitbekommen, was die anderen im Studio machen.
Ich war wirklich so in meiner eigenen Welt.
Aber insgesamt hat das überraschend gut funktioniert.
Jetzt am Ende des Spiels hat noch richtig viel Spaß gemacht.
Und ich bin super gespannt auf Tag 2.
Ehrlich gesagt, für Gaming kann ich mir das super vorstellen.
Ähm, arbeiten.
Damit es sich nicht so einfach macht.
Arbeiten?
Damit sehe ich jetzt noch keinen allzu großen Vorteil.
Das Office-Arbeiten.
Dann kommt die erste Herausforderung.
Zumal es halt auch nervig ist, den ganzen Tag so ein Ding aufzuhaben.
Ich habe jetzt einen Call und für diesen Call brauche ich eine Webcam.
Und dieses Ding hier kann mich zwar theoretisch in der Meta-App in 3D anzeigen, in einem Videocall,
aber leider telefoniere ich nicht mit Meta.
Dementsprechend benutzen die diese App nicht.
Und das bedeutet, ich muss mir jetzt irgendeine kreative Lösung finden.
Ich muss mir jetzt irgendeine kreative Lösung finden.
Zum Glück kann man jetzt ein iPhone als Webcam nutzen.
Ich habe jetzt dieses iPhone.
Da werden die aber ein bisschen blöd gucken, oder?
Wenn er so vor ihnen sitzt.
Mit dem Mac verbunden und beide wiederum streamen auf die Brille.
Das funktioniert alles für mich.
Ich kann alle sehen, die mit mir telefonieren wollen.
Und ich sehe auf jeden Fall meine digitalen Hände.
Und gleichzeitig meine echten Hände.
Das ist super skurril.
Aber die sehen mich im Videoanruf.
Mit dieser Brille im Gesicht.
Sie werden Fragen stellen, da bin ich mir sicher.
Danach schneide ich mein Video weiter und verfeinere die Notizen vom Videocall.
Akku leer.
Rote Striche im Gesicht, 100%.
In meinem Videoanruf hat niemand nachgefragt, was eigentlich los ist.
Es ist mega komisch, weil ich hatte so ein Ding im Gesicht.
Ich habe jetzt Nackenschmerzen und auch Rückenschmerzen.
Das Ding wiegt über 700g.
Als hätte man ein iPad den ganzen Tag auf dem Kopf.
Und das spüre ich jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen habe ich mir auch gedacht,
den ganzen Tag mit so einem Ding.
So der eigene Kopf ist halt
immer noch Beste.
Ja, und jetzt kann ich es halt wieder aufsetzen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen so.
Jetzt will ich auch mal andere Menschen treffen,
so wie es eigentlich gedacht ist.
Rec Room ist dafür beliebt, aber auch etwas chaotisch.
Es gibt Lobbys, wo Menschen einfach
sich treffen und herumlaufen können.
Die Grafik ist aber echt altbacken.
Das ist so Playstation 3 Niveau.
Da denke ich an vieles, aber nicht an die Zukunft.
Aber irgendwie gefällt mir...
Das sieht alles so billig aus.
Dieses ganze Metaverse Zeug.
Das sah ja fast Second Life besser aus
vor 20 Jahren.
Ansonsten, wenn die Leute was ordentliches spielen wollen,
wo viele drin sind,
sollen sie einfach VR Chat aufmachen.
...mir auch wie unfertig alles noch ist.
Es ist wie die Anfänge vom Internet.
Es gibt keinen Algorithmus.
Es sind einfach ein paar Menschen, die miteinander abhängen.
Ich meine, seriously, sowas baust du doch
in Unity oder Unreal
in einer Viertelstunde so einen Raum.
Ich habe mich gefragt, wie schädlich ist es eigentlich,
den ganzen Tag eine VR-Brille zu tragen.
Und es gibt noch nicht so viele Langzeitstudien.
Aktuell geht man davon aus,
dass es nicht weiter bedenklich ist.
Man könnte zwar meinen, dass der Iris-Muskel ermüdet,
weil man ja den ganzen Tag so nah fokussiert,
aber der wird durch die Linsen ausgetrickst.
Tatsächlich schaut man weiter in die Ferne
als bei einem normalen Computer.
Dass man unser Gehirn
ziemlich einfach austricksen kann,
hat ein sonderbares Experiment mit Kühen
verdeutlicht.
Denen wurde eine VR-Brille...
Ach du Scheiße!
Die arme Kuh, Mann!
Die arme Kuh, Alter!
Die Kuh, die denkt auch,
was ist mit mir los?
...aufgezogen, auf denen sie eine grüne Weide
gesehen haben und tatsächlich
brachten sie dadurch mehr Milch.
Wer sich Sorgen um Blue Light macht,
den kann ich beruhigen, denn man kann es natürlich reduzieren.
Trotzdem habe ich gemerkt, dass meine Augen
mehr ermüden als sonst.
Das liegt zum einen daran...
Ich kann es mir sogar wirklich vorstellen,
wenn das was bringt,
dass eine Kuh
mehr Milch gibt, es besser schmeckt
oder was auch immer,
dann stehen demnächst alle Kühe
virtuell auf der grünen Wiese.
Es ist alles eine Frage dessen,
wie teuer ist die Anschaffung?
Also lohnt sich's.
Das ist die eigentlich entscheidende Frage bei sowas.
Lohnt sich's.
...etwas mehr Starre und weniger Blinzel.
Zum anderen sind diese etwas
unschärferen Texte etwas, wo ich mich mehr konzentrieren muss.
Wenn ja, dann wird das gemacht.
Ja, man schaut halt durchgängig auf ein Display.
Bisher wurde die Brille immerhin nie heiß.
Es sprangen auch keine Lüfter an.
Heute ruckelt und laggt die Verbindung
irgendwie deutlich mehr als gestern.
Ich bearbeite die Aufnahmen vom Vortag,
in meinem Spielprogramm, und sie reagiert
super verzögert und träge.
Es muss am WLAN oder der Brille selbst liegen.
Es nervt auf jeden Fall sehr,
und von 90 oder 120 Hertz kann wirklich
nicht die Rede sein.
Die Zeit vergeht heute nicht wie im Flug.
Sie vergeht langsam, und ich habe Schwierigkeiten,
mich zu konzentrieren.
Ich nutze jede Ausrede, um die Brille kurz mal abzusetzen.
Meine Nackenschmerzen und Rückenschmerzen
sind unerträglich geworden.
Mein Kopf tut weh, und
ich will die Brille einfach nur noch absetzen.
Ich will die Brille einfach nur noch absetzen.
Oder die Kühe auf die Wiese lassen.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Kennt ihr das Gefühl, wenn ihr
bei einem Städtetrip über 30.000 Schritte
an einem Tag gelaufen seid, und
dann am nächsten Morgen wieder die Schuhe anziehen müsst?
Erst dann merkt ihr, wie erschöpft
eure Füße eigentlich noch sind.
Und so geht es mir heute.
Doch, du kannst ein Kabel anschließen.
Kabel kannst du anschließen, das geht.
Aber die Verbindung geht wahrscheinlich immer noch über WLAN.
Ein lustiges Video, und
dann ein Review, was mich interessiert.
Ich muss schon sagen, die großen Monitore sind
nach wie vor klasse.
Dann erlebe ich eine Unterwasserwelt in 3D,
und wie jemand mit einem Wingsuit aus einem Helikopter
springt.
Danach bin ich auf jeden Fall
euphorisch und motiviert.
Neben MetaHorizon Workroom gibt es
noch andere Apps, mit denen man den Computer
verbinden kann, und sie funktionieren
bei mir aber leider nur so lala.
Ich entscheide mich also ein bisschen, den Meta
eigenen Browser zu nutzen, indem ich meine
Tastatur und Maus direkt mit der Brille
verbinde, und das funktioniert alles super.
Wenn die Workrooms App so flüssig und schnell
wäre, dann würde das für mich alles ändern.
Obwohl die Farben der Brille nicht super
akkurat sind, mache ich ein bisschen Colorgrading
und schreibe dieses Skript weiter.
Inzwischen ist mir die Gestensteuerung ins Blut
übergegangen, und ich benutze die Controller wirklich
nur noch dann, wenn ich muss, und dann nerven sie
mich sogar. Die Performance heute ist viel
besser. Die Zeit bis zur Mittagspause vergeht
wie im Flug, und als der Akku leer ist, stecke
ich die Brille einfach kurz an und benutze sie dann weiter.
In der Pause gehe ich mit Robin etwas golfen,
was ultra Spaß macht.
Dass diese Brille so vielseitig ist,
das beeindruckt mich immer noch wie an
Tag 1. Meine visuelle Realität
wird einfach komplett überschrieben, und
deswegen ist nahezu alles möglich.
Ist Arbeiten in virtueller Realität
die Zukunft, oder schon
die Gegenwart? Bereits
9,4 Milliarden US-Dollar
hat Meta in die Entwicklung
gesteckt. Viele denken, dass das
ein Fehler ist, dass Mark Zuckerberg
seinen Verstand verloren hat, und
ich mag den Typen auch nicht, aber ich
bin inzwischen überzeugt, dass das die
richtige Entscheidung war. Sie wollen der
Welt.
Ich muss einfach sagen,
mit der
Metaverse hat das jetzt
wenig zu tun gehabt.
Man hat gesehen, dass es eine technisch
gute Brille ist und ein paar
VR-Anwendungen drauf.
Ansonsten hat es
nichts mit dem zu tun, was
man sich da vielleicht vorstellt. Man weiß
nicht mal, was man sich da genau vorstellt.
... virtuelle Realität sein, und bald
bekommen sie schon harte Konkurrenz.
Es ist schon ziemlich eindeutig, dass Apple bereits
im März seine VR-Brille ankündigen
wird, und die wird in einigen Punkten
besser... Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt,
weil wenn Apple was macht, dann
springen die ganzen Apple-Fanboys auf.
... als
die Quest Pro. Die Displays sollen
allein viermal so scharf sein, und
dadurch wird man fast keine Pixel mehr
sehen können. Sixteen Times... Nee.
Wie war das? Sixteen
Times the Detail, oder sowas.
Wie war das bei Fallout?
Apple wird eine Software haben, die
an iOS erinnert, nur halt in 3D.
Schon jetzt haben sie Avatare,
die die Augen und das Gesicht tracken können.
Die Animojis. Außerdem können sie
dank dem M2 einen viermal so
starken Prozessor verbauen und problemlos
iOS, iPad oder Mac Apps
virtuell laufen lassen. Sie starten
also nicht wie Meta, mit leeren Händen,
sondern sie haben direkt von Anfang an
Apps und sehr viele Entwickler,
die hinter Apple stehen. Auch beim Thema
Kamera und Pass-Through hat Apple
so viel mehr Erfahrung, was Bildqualität
angeht, dass ich davon überzeugt bin,
dass das Ganze richtig gut aussehen wird.
Ich glaube zwar auch, dass... Also da bin ich auch
schon überzeugt. Gut aussehen tut das meiste Zeug.
...gleich der Akkulaufzeit haben wird,
aber ganz ehrlich, das war hier nie
das Problem. Man steckt sie einfach an und
arbeitet weiter. Und wenn Apple dann noch MagSafe
verbaut, ist sogar das Anstecken super einfach.
Und ich mein, wem würdet ihr lieber
3000 Euro geben? Apple
oder Facebook?
Ehrlich gesagt, würde ich
die 3000 Euro am liebsten behalten.
Es sei denn, ich krieg was richtig Cooles für,
wo ich für mich persönlich den Anwendungszweck
gerade noch nicht sehe.
Also für Gaming?
Aber für tägliches Arbeiten?
Also, mal gucken.
Kann ich zurück an mein normales Setup?
Das Schöne an so Selbstexperimenten
ist, dass man etwas, was man früher
für selbstverständlich hingenommen hat, auf einmal
wieder richtig zu schätzen lernt.
Und jetzt grad bin ich richtig
aufgeregt darauf, meinen Monitor
wieder in voller Pracht zu sehen.
Sie sind
richtig, richtig schön.
Die Einstiegsfrage war,
ist VR nur so ein Spielzeug
oder kann man darauf auch arbeiten?
Und die Antwort ist, ja, man kann darauf arbeiten.
Man kann darauf arbeiten, die Frage ist bloß, warum sollte man?
Und es hat viel Potenzial
und wir kratzen ja gerade erst
noch die Oberfläche. Das ist alles noch
super, super neu.
Aber ich muss auch sagen,
das wäre natürlich auf Dauer nichts für mich gewesen.
Das wäre super anstrengend gewesen,
wieder so einen Monitor zu haben,
ohne einen roten Strich im Gesicht,
ohne, dass ich Nackenschmerzen kriege
oder Kopfschmerzen.
Das ist schon ein bisschen angenehmer.
Auch müssen diese Brillen noch kleiner werden
und cooler und natürlicher aussehen.
Aber es hat sich schon viel getan.
Ich meine, die sieht schon mal deutlich besser aus
und macht einen ökonomischeren Eindruck als die ersten paar Generationen.
1800 Euro.
Drei Monitore mit Full HD und in der Größe,
wo man sie hier drin sieht, würden etwa 600 Euro kosten.
Ich für meinen Teil bin jetzt
umso gespannter auf die Apple VR Brille
und auf das, was die Konkurrenz in nächster Zeit
so vorstellen wird.
Ich habe die Zukunft gesehen
und sie ist schon viel näher,
als ihr denkt.
Na dann.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Oder auch nicht.
Also ich könnte mir das nicht vorstellen,
damit den ganzen Tag zu arbeiten am Rechner.
Aber ich mag
mein Zwei-Monitor-Setup auch.
Da sind keine riesen Monitore.
Sind glaube ich 24 Zoll
oder so, was ich hier habe.
Ja, glaube. Bin mir gar nicht ganz sicher.
Zwei Stück nebeneinander, gut ist.
Ich persönlich mag auch zwei Monitore
lieber als irgendwie
so einen
Mega-Single-Monitor.
Aber kann man sich
unterschiedlichen Geschmack haben.
Jetzt ein schönes Katzenvideo.
Wir kriegen ja keins empfohlen.
99 Euro
Mini-PC bei Amazon
gekauft. Wirklich clever.
Kommt bestimmt drauf an,
was man machen will.
Was kriege ich da für komische Videos vorgeschlagen?
Ich weiß nicht mal,
wer Ara ist.
Ok, YouTube versucht mir wieder irgendwelches Zeug zu empfehlen.
Ist das legal?
4,5 Kilowatt
Solaranlage
selbst installieren.
Ich denke mal, dass das reine
installieren nicht das Problem ist.
Das anschließen
je nachdem, wie du es verwenden willst,
dürfte problematisch sein.
Das aufs Dach
bauen und so, das darfst du wahrscheinlich an einem Haus
machen, was du willst.
Warum nicht?
Gucken wir mal, geht nur 7 Minuten.
...module sind gerade super heiß.
Sehr viele Menschen wollen, welche haben,
egal ob als kleines Balkonkraftwerk
in der Mietwohnung oder so richtig
groß auf dem Eigenheimdach.
Das Problem ist nur, man findet sehr
viele Leute, die einem das...
Das und es ist teuer,
so was komplettes bauen zu lassen.
Deswegen habe ich das auch erstmal ein bisschen
aufgeschoben. Schauen wir mal,
wie sich das die nächsten Jahre über so entwickelt.
...Firma anruft, kann es gut sein,
dass die sagt, ja kostet
30.000 Euro, aber 2023
machen wir nichts mehr.
Bedeutet das,
dass man also ein Jahr lang
die frisch erhöhten Stromkosten zahlt,
obwohl auf dem Dach oder Balkon
noch so viel Platz eigentlich wäre?
Das stimmt wohl, allerdings die 30.000 Euro,
bis du die gespart hast, das
wird auch ein bisschen dauern.
Aber kann man das nicht einfach
selber machen? Das haben sich auch meine
drei CT-Kolleginnen und Kollegen Jan,
Pina und Andrian gefragt.
Die drei sind nämlich einfach zum Installateur
gegangen und haben ausgehandelt,
dass sie die Panels selber aufs Dach legen
und der Fachbetrieb am Ende alles
nur noch prüfen und den Anschluss machen muss.
700 Euro wollte der dafür
haben, was okay ist für die
Arbeit. Und das klingt ja erstmal super.
Viel Geld sparen und zusätzlich...
Das Dach ist ganz schön voll.
Mehr hätte er nicht drauf gepasst.
Wie schwer ist das?
Wie lange dauert das? Und vor allem
kriegen drei CTler gemeinsam
eine komplette Solardach-
Installation hin?
Die Knie haben
definitiv gelitten von ihm.
Aber das hat
richtig Einsatz gezeigt.
Das klären wir alles in diesem Video.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video
wird gesponsert von CyberGhost.
CyberGhost baut eine Versch...
Bis 600 Watt, also mit zwei
Solar-Panels zählt eine Anlage
als Balkon-Kraftwerk. Ja, das darf man.
Allerdings, allerdings,
ich hab mich da mal ein bisschen drüber
entfaltet. Allerdings darfst du ein Balkon-Kraftwerk
auch nur einmal daheim
hinstellen. Also du darfst jetzt nicht
an jedem Balkon ein Balkon-
Kraftwerk machen.
Dazu haben wir ja schon zwei Videos gemacht.
Für alle größeren Anlagen... Dann kannst du es einfach in die Steckdose stecken.
...muss ein Fachbetrieb als Errichter auftreten.
Aber die Beschränkung gilt nur für den
Anschluss ans Stromnetz selbst.
Alles, was mit Ziegeln, Schienenklemmen
und Gleichstromklemmen zu tun hat,
darf man im Prinzip selbst machen.
Also, Kollegen, kann ich mein Dach
einfach selber mit Solar
vollbauen? Ja, natürlich kann man eine
Photovoltaikanlage grundsätzlich auch selber installieren.
Ja, warum nicht?
Man braucht Module, man braucht
Installationsmaterial. Also dürfen darf man sicherlich auch.
Und man braucht Wechselrichter.
Das Installationsmaterial besteht aus
Dachhaken, die kommen auf den
Dachziegel, unter dem Dachziegel durchgeführt,
mit einer kleinen Aussparung.
Dann werden die festgeschraubt, darauf kommen
Aluprofil und daran werden Module
und Wechselrichter befestigt. Okay, das klingt jetzt
echt nicht so schwer, aber kann ich da denn...
Das ist, also ich glaube nicht, dass es
schwer ist in Form von, dass es jetzt irgendwie
kompliziert ist, aber
es ist wahrscheinlich anstrengend
as fuck. So richtig
grob was falsch machen?
Zum einen ist halt so die Sicherheit, wenn jemand rutscht,
da könnte was gefährlich sein,
also auf dem Dach arbeiten finde ich schon immer
was, wo ich so ein bisschen...
Also,
ich hätte meine
Bedenken, in mein Dach
Löcher zu
sägen, ehrlich gesagt.
Das würde ich nur
ungern machen. Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das hier ist jetzt ja nicht
sonderlich hoch. Also wenn hier einer
runter, wenn hier einer runterfällt,
da passiert
nichts. Wenn ich von meinem Dach runter
fallen würde, da wäre ich Matsch.
Ein mulmiges Gefühl im Bauch
habe. Weil, das kannst
du, also das ist ja, wenn du hier runterfällst,
ich mein,
du tust dir ein bisschen weh, aber
viel passieren wird da wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ansonsten,
die Ziegeln könnten brechen,
wir müssen da so Aussparungen machen,
das ist unter Umständen
ein Problem, müssen wir mal schauen.
Okay, aber Solarpanels erzeugen ja
Gleichstrom, im Stromnetz fließt
natürlich Wechselstrom. Da braucht man ja
nur noch so einen Wechselrichter.
Wie habt ihr das denn jetzt gelöst?
Wir haben uns aufgrund der Verschattung der Garage,
auf der wir die Anlage installiert haben,
für Mikrowechselrichter entschieden, also
kleine, kleinere Wechselrichter, die
direkt aufs Dach kommen, ans Profil,
auf dem die Solarmodule auch aufliegen.
Chet, das heißt nicht, dass du da runter
springen sollst, aber es macht einen Unterschied,
ob du irgendwie in, weiß ich, zwei Meter
Höhe bist, oder in zwölf Meter
Höhe. Anders als bei
größeren Stringanlagen, wo die ganzen Gerätschaften
in der Regel in den Keller kommen. Wir haben jetzt hier
zwei Stück verwendet, für insgesamt zwölf
Module, direkt am Profil montiert.
Das macht ja hier auch eigentlich total Sinn.
Wir haben nämlich eine ziemlich schwierige Situation
eigentlich. Die Garage, um die es hier geht,
die ist teilverschattet. Auf der einen Seite steht eine Scheune,
auf der anderen ein Wohnhaus.
Inzwischen sind viele Module, große Teile
der Zeit, in der Sonne, aber immer mal wieder
einzelne Bereiche im Schatten. Und bei einer
konventionellen Anlage mit einem String
Ja genau, ist halt die Frage, ob die
Ausrichtung hier auch so sinnvoll ist. Aber es ist
ja nur ein Test, ob sie es selbst
hinkriegen. Wäre bei
Teilverschattung sofort die Anlage
insgesamt sehr, sehr wenig performant, und mit
diesen Mikrowechselrichtern können wir das umgehen.
Also die Anlage der drei
liefert ja dann mehr als vier Kilowatt,
also auch mehr als eine normale
Sicherung aushält. Ein Haus
ist aber ja nicht nur mit einer Phase
angeschlossen, sondern mit drei. Und über
die dürfen jeweils, soweit ich
weiß, 32 Ampere fließen.
Aber die Kabel im Haus müssen auch dick genug
sein, damit die nicht so heiß werden, oder?
Muss man da irgendwas beachten?
Ich würde sowas trotzdem nicht selber bauen.
Also es wäre mir viel zu aufwendig,
und ich hätte Schiss auf meinem Dach
hier oben rumzutouren.
Man kann es davon abgesehen haben,
auf das Dach kommt man ohne Gerüst gar nicht
richtig drauf.
Also man kann wahrscheinlich, also
man könnte, ich weiß gar nicht,
man könnte wahrscheinlich
vom
Dachboden
die Leiter
hoch, irgendwie, und
dann da wahrscheinlich
irgendwie raus.
Ich hab, ich hab ein Fenster,
allerdings ist das Fenster nicht am Dach,
sondern daneben.
Nee, nee, also ich hab, ich hab kein Fenster,
was wirklich so das Dach, am Dach
aufklappt, nee. Also ich müsste
dann, wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich könnte ich bei mir auf
den Dachboden dort die Treppe
hoch, und dann dort irgendwie
raus, wenn man von innen
was wegnimmt, oder so, weil, kein
Schimmer.
16 Ampere CE-Dose dran, das Ganze
ist direkt verbunden in einer
kleinen, relativ kleinen Dose.
Das werden wir alles rückbauen, bis zu dem Kabel,
was in die Garage kommt, werden dann einen kleinen
Verteilerkasten setzen, und da
reinkommen verschiedene Sicherungen,
eine LS plus FI-Sicherung,
und zwei 3x 16 Ampere
Automaten. Und dann kommt
die CE-Dose.
Das, das gute Wera Elektriker
Set hat er am Start. Wieder auf eine
Sicherung, und die Photovoltaikanlage
kommt mit auf eine
3x 16 Ampere Kombi-Sicherung.
Also, wer sich jetzt nicht unbedingt
zutraut, selbst Sicherungskästen
zu setzen, sollte diesen Teil natürlich
der Installationsfirma überlassen.
Die schiebt den Auftrag, wenn man Glück hat,
ja trotzdem kurzfristig dazwischen,
solange zumindest keine Arbeit
Ja, also ich musste
sieben, ist ungelogen, sieben
Elektrikläden anrufen,
bei mir, dass ich in nächster Zeit
mein Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto bekommen
hab. Und da musste man auch nicht viel machen.
... auf dem Dach selbst gemacht werden müssen.
Was ich jetzt aber noch nicht ganz verstanden habe,
wie lange hat denn jetzt insgesamt
die Installation der Solaranlage
gedauert? Wir haben vier Tage gebraucht,
am ersten Tag sind wir erstmal hier angekommen,
nachmittags, haben das Gerüst aufgebaut
an der Garage und haben dann losgelegt
mit der ersten von vier Reihen Dachhaken,
die wir an dem ersten Abend dann noch
... abgeschlossen haben.
Ja, zweiter Tag waren
die anderen Dachhaken, das hat
ein bisschen mehr als über den Mittag gedauert.
Da haben wir noch die Schienen drauf gemacht
und eins der Module
hatten wir auch schon am zweiten Tag.
Ja, am dritten Tag haben wir die Module eingedeckt
Ja, der Platz ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht
der beste, aber ich glaube es ging hauptsächlich um den
Versuch, ob man das selbst hinkriegt.
Was hast du für ein Auto? Ich habe einen
Fiat 500e.
... den zweiten Wechselrichter gesetzt und am Abend
noch damit begonnen die Elektrik vorzubereiten.
Auf dem Dachboden der Garage das Kabel
nach unten geführt, um dann
alles bereit zu haben für den vierten Tag.
Genau, dann haben wir nicht
den ganzen Tag gebraucht, aber
schon einige Stunden dann in der Garage
die Elektrik gemacht.
Der Testbetrieb ist abgeschlossen, die Anlage
war mal kurz am Netz, ist jetzt wieder aus
und wartet auf die Freigabe
durch den Netzbetreiber, aber wir sind
soweit zuversichtlich.
Wo ist das Problem, solange sie es ordentlich machen?
Also ich würde es trotzdem
ganz ehrlich, ich hätte da
keine Ambition. Aber davon
abgesehen, ich könnte es bei uns auch gar nicht.
Da müsste ich wirklich auf, ich weiß nicht wie hoch
das ist, aber es ist deutlich höher,
viel schlechter zugänglich.
Ich denke auch, dass wahrscheinlich, wenn das
jemand professionell machen würde,
würden die wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Gerüst hinstellen
oder so. Also bei mir hier war es aufs Dach
zu machen, wird erstens
abfuck teuer und
ich glaube nicht, dass es sich so
wahnsinnig lohnt, wenn man sich die Kosten
anguckt, plus das, was man vielleicht
dadurch sparen würde. Also rein fürs Geld sparen,
glaube ich, macht es bei mir keinen Sinn.
Die Anlage lief
und hat schon die erste Energie
geliefert. Also ich bin
ziemlich beeindruckt, muss ich sagen. Also
das hätte ich so nicht hinbekommen.
Ich habe aber auch nicht so das Heimwerker-Gen
Ich hätte es auch nicht hinbekommen, ich hätte auch keinen Bock drauf.
Aber vielleicht sind ein paar von euch
ja auch so mutig und begabt.
Dieses Video soll euch ein bisschen Mut
machen, die Energiewende selbst
mit anzupacken. Ja,
jedenfalls am Ende haben die drei für ihre
Anlage auf der Garage insgesamt nicht
mal 5000 Euro bezahlt
und mit dem gesparten Strom und den
7 Cent Einspeisevergütung
für die überschüssigen Kilowattstunden
sollten sie das Geld in weniger
als fünf Jahren locker wieder
drin haben.
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare, ob
das so ist.
Ich glaube, dass es
in fünf Jahren kann viel passieren.
Da darf auch nichts kaputt gehen.
Wobei fünf Jahre noch eine überschaubare Zeit ist.
Das ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Da kann man sich das überlegen.
Fünf Jahre ist, finde ich, etwas Überschaubares.
Andere, die dann irgendwie sagen, ja,
nach 15 Jahren oder so, wer weiß,
ob die Panels überhaupt so lange halten.
Die Anlage selbst zu bauen.
Mich würde vor allem interessieren,
wenn ihr das vor habt, es aber aus irgendeinem Grund nicht geht.
Die sich quer stellen.
Das Problem mit Vermietern habe ich nicht.
Tschüss.
Da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf, das selbst zu machen.
Also sollte ich mir was installieren
lassen,
dann lasse ich das auf jeden Fall machen.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht,
dass es hier in nächster Zeit
Solar auf dem Dach
geben wird.
Das sieht aus wie ein...
Nee, ist es nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es sieht aus wie ein Fireship-Video.
Also, es ist das Ende des Jahres
und ich habe kein regelmäßiges
Video für diese Woche, aber ich wollte
die Kamera einfach anstellen.
Okay, was auch immer.
Geht ganz normal weiter.
Ey, ist überhaupt nicht done.
Das ist ja wie früher auf YouTube, die Videos.
Ich höre auf, ich lösche meinen Kanal.
Und irgendwie zwei Tage später
nächstes Video.
InScope-Lifestyle, alles klar.
Naja.
Ja gut.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Ey, was ist das?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Ich glaube in einem Fireship-Video
habe ich das gesehen.
Da musst du dich
wundern, wenn dich in irgendeinem
Online-Meeting auf einmal einer
den ganzen Tag anguckt.
Da denkst du dir so, hm.
Weil der guckt dich ja nicht an.
Das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Ist eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
Das ist ein bisschen zu auffällig,
wenn du es dir nachempfängst?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen
zu auffällig, aber
wenn der dir dann mal
anguckt, dann ist das
das Verstehen, was er
mit dem Fokus hat.
Also, wenn du jetzt
dir in einer Videocall
be elections
frühstündig bist,
dann ist das eigentlich
das eigentliche.
Ja, genau.
Man müsste einstellen können, dass das ab und zu halt auch mal wegguckt, dass es realistischer, glaubhafter wirkt.
Ansonsten ist es eine coole Technik.
Realer Irrsinn, was? Das Wanderurinal in Köln. Was zum?
Dies ist die Geschichte eines kleinen Urinals.
Es steht schon länger am großen Ebertplatz in Köln und fristet ein Nischendasein.
Dabei will die Stadt mit dem Örtchen doch nur helfen und Wildpinklern eine zivilisierte Form der Erleichterung geben.
Boah, das Ding sieht so aus, als würde ich da nicht auf 50 Meter rangehen.
Doch vor allem erfährt es Ablehnung.
Also man soll dann pinkeln und in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Von oben kann man dann filmen.
Ja, theoretisch.
Menschen, die hier vorbeikommen, fühlen sich gestört. Der Enkel auch, der riecht es schon vom Weiten.
Ich muss auch sagen, dass auch hier so eine Brise...
Das stinkt halt als Fuck, ja.
Die Stadt Köln bekommt mitleid.
Erst mal kurz neben dem Gehweg eine Runde pissen gehen.
Vor allem guckt mal, wie rum das steht. Da laufen die Leute vorbei, während er da an ein Ding reint.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Im kleinen Urinal und stellt ihm ein zweites zur Seite.
Deutlich prominenter platziert direkt neben dem Imbiss.
Beste Posi, Alter.
Unsere Gäste hauptsächlich, die sind aufgestanden und gegangen.
Wenn ein Klo nicht vernünftig gereinigt wird.
Beste Posi direkt neben dem Imbiss.
Vor allem, weil dann die Leute beim Mittagessen...
Ach Gott, das ist...
Wind weht und man in dem Wind sitzt, dann stinkt es extrem.
Die Stadt reagiert.
Der Gastronom hatte sich in den heißen Monaten aufgrund der Geruchsentwicklung
trotz höherem Leerungsrhythmus einen anderen Standort gewünscht.
Also geht das Urinal auf Reisen.
Und zwar zunächst einmal über den Platz direkt neben...
...das Basketballfeld.
Mittendrin, statt nur dabei.
Da spielen die doch Ball.
Das ist so unpraktisch.
Mütter und Kinder haben dann...
Wie wär's ohne Scheiß, wie wär's einfach mit irgendwie so zwei, drei Dixi-Klos oder sowas?
Wenn's denn wirklich da Klo braucht an der Stelle.
Männer beim Urinieren zu gucken können, wenn sie denn da verweilen wollten.
Erneut gibt es Beschwerden.
Immer noch will niemand das Urinal haben.
Also geht es weiter.
Warum das jetzt hier so rum, weil das ist mir ein Rätsel.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Die Stadt weiß eine Antwort.
Es wird versucht, allen AkteurInnen Ideen und Beschwerden gerecht zu werden.
Weil da garantiert innen drauf geht.
Der nächste Standort direkt neben dem U-Bahn-Ausgang.
Etwas äh irritierend.
Das ist ja dann das, wenn die Leute von der U-Bahn rauskommen, als allererstes quasi äh...
Sehen sie einen beim Pisten.
...in den Genuss kommen des Urinals.
Das ist zum Kotzen für eine Frau, weil wenn sie da dran vorbeigehen und es entlädigt...
...sich einer, ist das kein Anblick.
Wir Frauen...
Naja, ich find's auch nicht sonderlich toll.
...können das auch nicht.
Also muss das Urinal noch mal umziehen.
Wenn ich da einen zu gu... so sehen muss.
...zum Basketballfeld und weiter zum U-Bahn-Ausgang geht es noch ein Stückchen weiter...
...neben die Fahrradbügel.
Jetzt müssten doch alle zufrieden sein mit diesem Alleskönner.
Alter, das sieht so abartig aus.
Da, wie, ich würd da, ich würd da auf 50, ich würd 50 Meter Abstand halten.
Sicherheitsabstand.
Egal wie, es ist nicht schön und es ist keine gute Lösung.
Ich glaub, der Druck muss schon sehr hoch sein, um da hinzugehen.
Ich finde, das ist nirgendwo angemessen.
Das ist auch würdelos für Menschen, die wirklich ein Bedürfnis haben, ihren Notdruck zu verrichten.
Außer der Stadt scheint niemand das kleine Urinal zu mögen.
Nur weil sie etwas zu öffentlich ist, diese öffentliche Toilette.
Schwachsinn.
Zack.
Mein Name ist Christian...
Ja.
...und ich, seriously, wenn's so dringend ist,
dann würd ich mir auch irgendeinen Baum oder irgendeinen Busch suchen,
bisschen, bisschen versteckt und würd da hinpinkeln,
anstatt an dieses Teilnehmer der U-Bahn-Station.
Also, das war ja auch, ja...
Das wollen sie verhindern damit, ja, funktioniert halt net.
Man könnte auch, stellt euch mal vor, überlegt euch mal, imagine,
es gäbe an Bahnhöfen noch Klos, in die man rein könnte und da auch reingehen will.
Wenn, wenn man mal muss.
Also sprich, die in nem Zustand sind, dass man sie benutzen kann.
Dann bräuchte man das meiste nämlich gar nicht.
Aber das geht natürlich net.
Vielleicht sogar noch ohne, meinetwegen, meinetwegen darf's sogar einen Euro kosten.
Christian Lindner interviewt, das kenn ich, das kenn ich, das ist schon, schon paar Wochen alt.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Was verdient man als selbstständiger Kfz-Mechaniker?
Pura gearbeitet als Kfz-Meister, umgangssprachlich...
Ach, Kfz-Technikmeister, umgangssprachlich Kfz-Meister.
Alles klar.
Wenn ihm der Laden gehört, dann wahrscheinlich ordentlich.
Ansonsten...
Wahrscheinlich nicht so viel.
Weil man hat halt viel Verantwortung.
Im schlimmsten Fall kommt er halt nicht mehr zum Bremsen und dann könnte halt Personenschaden entstehen.
Als Selbstständiger kann man schon irgendwann mehr verdienen.
Irgendwann mehr verdienen, als wenn man angestellt ist.
Hallo, ich bin der Burak.
Ich hoffe, die haben keine TOS-Musik wieder im Hintergrund.
Seid ihr gestern fertig geworden mit dem Emulator-PC?
Na, ganz fertig ist man nie, aber es hat funktioniert alles.
28 Jahre alt.
Wir haben sogar Achievements reingepackt.
Mit Add-on Achievements reingepackt.
Wii emuliert.
Und so Zeug, ja.
Kfz-Technikermeister.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Okay, dem gehört der Laden, ne? Dann kommt bestimmt ordentlich was rum.
Werkstatt.
Wir haben heute viel zu tun.
Wird ein anstrengender Tag.
Aber schaffen wir schon.
Es ist nicht nur eine Marke, die wir betreuen, sondern im Prinzip jedes PKW wird von uns repariert.
Wenn man hartnäckig ist und gut dran bleibt, dann regelt man auch den Fehler.
Gute HP-Monitore.
Wir haben halt so die hauptsächliche Herausforderung.
Hier habe ich die ersten zwei Aufträge gleich, die ich an die Jungs bzw. an die Mitarbeiter verteilen werde.
Moin.
Moin, Paolo.
Wie geht's?
Alles gut?
Moin, Moin.
So Jungs, wir haben heute relativ viel zu tun.
Macht der Chef erstmal Ansprache.
Auf geht's.
Wir fangen mit den zwei Aufträgen an.
Also, Paolo, du machst bitte vier neue Reifen bei dem Jeep.
Und, Marduf, du machst hier eine Inspektion.
Ja.
Mit Ölwechsel.
Alles klar.
Frohes Schaffen.
Also, ich selber mache viel Organisatorisches.
Ich bin ja auch im Prinzip der Kopf der Firma.
Morgen in Ümme hier von B&O, bitteschön.
Die Planung, die Kundeneinplanung, die Disponierung.
Ich frage mich immer, warum Leute diese Low-Profile-Tastaturen mögen.
Ich gebe zu, hat mit dem Videoinhalt nichts zu tun.
Ich komme mit diesen Dingen einfach nicht klar.
Ich mag keine Low-Profile-Tastaturen.
Mir ist es auch unbegreiflich, dass Leute damit gut arbeiten können.
Die Regulierung von den Aufträgen, die Vorbereitung.
Ich hatte auch von Logitech jahrelang auf der Arbeit eine.
Ich komme damit nicht klar.
Ich mag die null.
Ein ungeplanter Kunde.
Guten Tag.
Bitteschön.
Hi.
Haben wir wirklich Ölverlust am Auto?
Ja.
Also, es ist nicht kein Motoröl, sondern eher irgendwie was anderes.
Könnt ihr das machen?
Okay.
Gucken wir uns sofort an.
Boah.
Nicht schlecht.
Normalerweise, wenn man da anruft, sagen sie, ja, nächste Woche könnten wir noch irgendwie vielleicht.
Könnte natürlich was Wichtiges sein.
Wenn es jetzt als Beispiel Bremsflüssigkeit ist, dann wäre es schon gefährlich.
Switch-Emulation habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Kommt halt nicht mehr zum Bremsen und dann könnte halt Personenschaden entstehen.
Da sehe ich schon etwas.
Das kommt hier vom Getriebe, also der Simmerring von der Antriebswelle.
Das ist im Prinzip so eine Dichtung, können Sie sich vorstellen.
Von der Antriebswelle.
Da an der Stelle verliert er das Getriebeöl.
Also, Sie sehen das hier, das ist schon richtig viel.
Da würde ich Ihnen raten, dass wir die nächsten Tage, dass wir danach schauen, das Problem
beheben.
Und da würde ich Ihnen aber nicht raten, viel mitzufahren.
Am besten gar nicht, weil dann könnte das Getriebe im schlimmsten Fall kaputt gehen.
So, ich mache Ihnen dann soweit im Laufe des Tages den Kostenvorschlag fertig.
Dann melde ich mich bei Ihnen telefonisch.
Genau.
Dann bedanke ich, dass Sie da waren und dann sprechen wir uns.
Alles klar.
Schönen Tag noch.
Danke.
Ciao.
Brauchen die dafür irgendwelche speziellen Teile oder warum können die denn nicht einfach
gleich da behalten und machen?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es zu voll ist, oder?
Oder ist das irgendwie, müssen die dafür, ja gut, vielleicht muss man für das Auto
was Spezielles bestellen.
Vita-Emulatoren gibt es ja.
Die Anfangszeit, da kann ich mich sehr gut dran erinnern.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, werden überhaupt Kunden kommen?
Werde ich überhaupt jeden Tag Arbeit haben?
Naja, dass da andere vorher dran sind, ist ja okay.
Aber man könnte es ja beispielsweise dort auf den Hof stellen, wenn der in der Nähe
wohnt und es dann morgen machen, bevor er da hin und zurück fährt jetzt mit kaputtem
Auto.
Es lief aber von Anfang an schon relativ gut an.
Aber man hat natürlich immer Existenzängste, weil man hat halt viel Verantwortung.
Das ist jetzt bei circa 250 Euro.
Geht doch voll klar.
250 Euro, geht doch voll klar.
Ihr wollt nicht wissen, was ich für meinen kaputtenden Reifen und Felge mit Schramme bezahlen musste.
Hallo, hier ist Ömi von B&O.
Ich rufe von der Werkstatt an.
Wegen dem Fahrzeug habe ich jetzt den Kostenvoranschlag fertig gemacht.
Genau, 251.
Zusammen kommen wir auf knapp 250 Euro.
Ja?
Okay, dann sehen wir uns diesen Freitag um 8 Uhr.
Schönen Tag noch.
Ciao.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Steh auf.
Ja, geht natürlich.
Ja?
Geht gut.
Ah.
Erst mal die gute Pizza reinhalten.
Thunfisch.
Thunfisch excellent.
Oder, was ist das?
Das sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie Thunfisch, ne?
Excellent-Pizza.
Thunfisch Poggo.
Das scannen wir das Paket mal.
So, bitteschön.
Schönen Tag noch, ja?
Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.
Das setzen wir großartig an Nebenverdienst dazu, aber.
Ach, ist das doch ein Paketshop, oder wie?
Ist das doch ein Paketshop, oder wie?
Das ist ein Betrag.
dass das natürlich auch für uns Werbung irgendwo ist. Viele wissen auch zum Beispiel nicht, dass
wir auch hier eine Werkstatt haben, weil das schon ein bisschen abgelegen auch ist. Wie geht's Ihnen?
Alles gut soweit? Paketshop? Dann machen wir jetzt die Batterie. Aber da braucht er einen,
der sich da tagsüber drum kümmert. Das kann er nicht in der Mittagspause 30 Minuten machen. Die
Leute kommen ja tagsüber ihr Paket ab. Oder macht er das dann? Alles klar, bitteschön. Bis gleich.
Warum ich mich selbstständig gemacht habe? Erstens, ich wollte halt in gewissem Maßen frei
sein, weil als Angestellter ist man natürlich an den Vorgesetzten gebunden. Und natürlich auch das
Finanzielle, weil als Selbstständiger kann man da schon irgendwann mehr verdienen, als wenn man
angestellt ist. Letztendlich hast du halt auch mehr Risiko und das muss sich halt dementsprechend
rechnen. Paolo, kannst du mir mal eben kurz helfen? Ja.
Ich hole direkt die neue, dann heben wir die zusammen auch nochmal ein. Ich war im Sprinterwerk
in Düsseldorf, also da, wo die Mercedes Sprinter gebaut werden. Da habe ich auch sehr gut verdient,
aber da ist dann auch die Grenze irgendwann auch festgesetzt, bis wohin man auch verdienen kann.
Als Selbstständiger sieht das natürlich anders aus. Da hat man eigentlich keine Grenzen.
Da hängt
von seiner eigenen unternehmerischen Fähigkeiten ab. Trifft es da glaube ich am besten. Also wirklich
reich werden die wenigsten. Pleite gehen auch einige. Ich denke mal, bei den meisten wird
sich so halbwegs ausgehen. Hat der Wasser eintritt? Ja. Das zeige ich dem Kunden am besten mal direkt,
damit er das mal sieht. Ja, du kannst vielleicht die Batterie selbst wechseln. Ich würde meine
Batterie auch nicht selbst wechseln. Gut, beim Elektroauto jetzt schon mal gar nicht. Beim
Elektroauto ist es Batterie wechseln, dann ist es die Batterie wechseln, dann ist es die Batterie
wechseln, dann ist es die Batterie wechseln, dann ist es die Batterie wechseln, dann ist es die Batterie
wechseln, dann ist das halbe Auto weg. Jetzt gerade festgestellt, dass da, wo die Batterie
drin sitzt, ja, Wassereintritt ist. Und das ist natürlich gar nicht gut im Innenraum. Wir haben
die alte Batterie rausgehoben. Und wenn Sie hier in das Fach rein gucken, wo die Batterie drin sitzt,
sehen Sie, dass da Wassereintritt ist. Müssen wir schauen, also die Stoßstange
eventuell runternehmen, so weit abdichten. Das würde ich Ihnen an der Stelle eigentlich
empfehlen dann zwei termin nur das wollte ich mal
gezeigt haben dann bin ich gleich bei ihm wieder
paulo können wir noch mal eben kurz rein heben kritische musik ja mein
jahresumsatz 2000 1202 133.000 euro man hat sehr viel kosten also miete und das
sagt er das sagt ja gar nicht wollte gerade sagen also umsatz ist ja nur das
alles was reingekommen ist an kohle weiß ich wie viel mitarbeiter hat was er
alles ausgibt das sagt ja so ganz mal nichts dann kommt natürlich auch
materialkosten ein jahresgewinn nach steuer 2021 war circa 28.000 euro
ich hatte jeden monat gute 2300 euro zur verfügung
trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz trotz ich
muss jetzt irgendwas sagen weil an
sonst weiß ich nicht wann es weitergeht und ansonsten ist die musik viel zu
trotz ich weiß nicht was das für ist es hat garantiert trotz ok excellent kein
trotz mehr es gibt ein problem die anzeige dass die bremse fällig ist da
leuchtet er die kontrolle auf die ist immer noch an
obwohl die bremse jetzt neues da vermute ich dass der verschleißsensor da ein
problem hat also die klammer die
verschleißsensor der neue der wird der hat da gar nicht reingepasst sozusagen
wachsen tauschen wir dann morgen soweit soweit auch noch um dann ist die
fehlermeldung dann auch hoffentlich weg man kann eigentlich alles voraus planen
manchmal kommt es leider verkehrt bis morgen wenn ich den gesamten tag heute
zusammenfassen müsste war das ein erfolgreicher tag ist hat eigentlich
alles soweit gut geklappt bis auf jetzt die kleinigkeit mit dem verschleißsensor
bis ihr was glaubt?
ich glaube ich da auch ein problem ist wenn man so handelt wenn man generell
mein handwerker ist dass viele leute nicht bezahlen
ich glaube das ist wirklich problematisch gerade wenn es ein bisschen was größere
mmm auto magst jetzt noch halbwegs gehen ja die bestellen die ganzen teile das
wird er danach bezahlt aber generell das einfach leute nicht bezahlen ist glaube
ich wirklich ein großes problem was du als handwerker hast und wenn das einen
gewissen anteil über steil klar du kannst dann alles mit mann verfahren
und sonst was. Ja, und die meisten werden
vielleicht dann auch bezahlen.
Aber
ich denke, wenn das
schon ein relativ geringer
Prozentsatz ist, macht das so viel aus,
dass du es nicht mehr betreiben
kannst. Also je nachdem, was es ist.
Also bei einer Autowerkstatt
geht es vielleicht noch, aber wenn du
irgendwelche größeren Baumaßnahmen
machst oder so, kann ich mir das
wirklich schwierig, stelle ich mir das wirklich
schwierig vor, wenn Leute einfach nicht bezahlen oder
viel zu spät bezahlen.
Ich leise dann so.
Dann wünsche ich dir einen schönen Feierabend, Paolo.
Und dann sehen wir uns
nochmal. Ja, wenn die sich zu viel Zeit lassen
mit der Rechnung, dann müssen sie
dich nicht beschweren. Aber ich kriege eigentlich, also
mir fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt nichts ein.
Doch, doch, mir fällt was ein.
Tatsächlich.
Die, die bei uns die Dachtreppe,
also die, die, nicht die Dachtreppe,
die für
also den
Dachboden, die Treppe für den
Dachboden gebaut haben, die haben
glaube ich auch
zwei, drei Monate oder so
gebraucht, bis sie dann endlich mal die Rechnung
geschickt haben. Ich glaube du kannst, ich glaube
du hast, du hast
ein halbes Jahr darfst du
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, gibt es ja irgendwelche
so, so, so Verjährungsdinger
wie das
ist. Also
zwischen
Kaufmännern, das weiß ich noch
das weiß ich noch so ungefähr
ungefähr
ich habe ja mal
ein bisschen BWL-Zeug gemacht, ich kriege das gar
nicht mehr genau.
Also ich weiß, dass es zwischen
Kaufleuten andere Sachen
gelten als zwischen
Privatpersonen und
zum Beispiel kannst du
auch als Kaufmann
zwischen Kaufmann einem Vertrag
zustimmen, ohne dass du explizit
sagst, dass du zustimmst.
Das nennt sich dann glaube ich
konkludierende Handlung
oder sowas, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe.
Manche
Sachen habe ich mir von meinem BWL
Scheiß doch noch gemerkt.
Ja, auch wenn ich damit nichts mehr,
auch wenn ich damit nicht nichts mehr zu tun
haben will, ist das ein Reiter auf
der Brust?
Ich glaube nicht.
Slave
als Ring.
Alles geht noch als Privat.
Das ist der Chat.
Ich weiß, ihr blickt noch besser durch als ich.
Ja,
wie geht's?
Alles gut, Mama, Beste.
Jetzt ist gut, ja, ich
sehe noch kein Bedürfnis,
dass ich meine eigene Wohnung habe.
Also solange ich kann, will ich.
Es ist auch sinnvoll.
Ich meine, er ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie.
14 Stunden oder so als Chef auf der Arbeit.
Zwischen meinen Eltern sein.
Es sei denn, ich, wenn ich heirate oder
die Frau meines Lebens finde.
Klar, dann ist das eine andere Geschichte.
Ja, man kann sagen, der ist auch außer schlafen
ist er wahrscheinlich nie daheim und kümmert sich ums Geschäft.
Also ist doch sehr sinnvoll.
Wobei ich dann ich habe letztens irgendwo auf Twitter oder Instagram
im Instagram Screenshots gesehen.
Da haben sich Mädels darüber ausgetauscht, welche.
Welche Männer man nicht daten darf.
Und relativ weit oben war Leute, die noch zu Hause wohnen.
Da hätte ich meine Schwierigkeiten hier schon mal.
Ich meine, ich wohne noch zu Hause, auch wenn das mein Zuhause,
aber ich wohne zu Hause und IT und IT.
Das heißt im Prinzip doppelt.
Doppelt gelitten.
Ja, cake weight.
Wir haben verkackt komplett.
Oder oder die Mädels haben verkackt.
Die wissen ja auch nicht, was sie verpassen.
Also man kann das so und so sehen.
Man kann es davon abgesehen.
Glücklicherweise repräsentiert Instagram nicht die reine Wahrheit.
Es lohnt sich für mich auf jeden Fall,
weil ich durch die Arbeit, durch die Auftragslage von Tag zu Tag eigentlich
meinen Zielen.
Meinen Träumen näher komme und ja, was am Ende rauskommt,
steigt auch der Umsatz, der Gewinn.
Und ich denke definitiv für mich lohnt sich das auf jeden Fall.
Also richtig krass viel kommt noch nicht rum.
Aber ich meine, er hat ja immerhin die Chance, durch durch eigene.
Ja, unternehmerische.
Skills, das zu verbessern.
Ja, es liegt quasi ganz in seiner Hand.
Und das ist ja auch anscheinend das, was er will.
Also kann durchaus Stonks steil bergauf gehen die nächsten Jahre über.
Das war's heute von mir.
Danke, dass ihr mich begleitet habt.
Hier findet der Maschinenbau Ingenieur und aber wisst ihr, was ich interessant
finde bei diesen ganzen bei diesen diesen ganzen lohnt sich das Videos?
Du hast auf der einen Seite Leute.
Da hast du den Eindruck.
Die schaffen halt auch irgendwie den Tag über was und dann hast du manchmal.
Jobs, wo ich mich frage, was machen die eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Also für mich das schlimmste Beispiel von Was machen die eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
War diese Unternehmensberaterin oder was das, was das gewesen ist?
Ja, die hier selbst.
Ne Moment, war die das?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, da habe ich gefragt, was zum Teufel?
Macht die eigentlich auch den?
Was macht ihr den ganzen Tag?
Das Einzige, was wir gesehen haben, was sie wirklich macht, sind irgendwelche Excel-Tabellen
und dann die die Tabelle mit irgendeinem besprechen.
Das macht ihr den ganzen Tag?
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Anscheinend ist es so, dass es das ist wahrscheinlich so ein typischer Bullshit Job,
den eigentlich keiner braucht, die es aber trotzdem gibt.
Kleiner ist der Anteil dieser Jobs mittlerweile.
Anteilmäßig finde ich zu hoch EcoFlow Delta 2.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Eine große Power Bank.
Das sieht aus wie eine große USV oder eine große Power Bank.
Ich meine, USV ist ja eigentlich so eine Hard Power Bank.
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur ab und zu?
Ich habe, ich habe gehört, der Friseur ist jetzt Unterwäsche Model.
Das liegt an den Unternehmensprozessen.
Ja, ja, die Dienstleister sind nicht das Problem.
Es ist ja klar.
Der Dienstleister, der was anbietet, kann ja gar nicht die Ursache sein,
sondern derjenige, der Dienstleister einkauft.
Also es gäbe die Dienstleister gar nicht,
wenn es keine Unternehmen geben würde, die sie alle haben wollen.
So, das ist ja klar. Sturz von Netflix.
3D Drucker schreibt meine Hausaufgaben.
Ich, ich glaube nicht, dass uns das als.
Okay, gucken wir mal, bevor ich, bevor ich jetzt, ich glaube nicht,
dass uns das als als Technik begeisterte Leute hier sonderlich beeindruckt.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich habe mittlerweile jeder von ChatGPT gehört, eine KI,
mit der man ganz normal hin und her schreiben kann,
die auf quasi alles eine nuancierte, gute Antwort hat.
Auf Wunsch.
Naja, wir haben gestern festgestellt, ChatGPT ist da auch etwas unbedarft,
gerade wenn es um Linux Befehle geht und um was haben wir?
Wo hat es gestern gesagt?
Habe ich keine? Achso, ob Solution das Fortnite Turnier gewinnen wird?
Ja, das wusste sie natürlich auch nicht.
Ja, aber eins muss man sagen.
Diese ChatGPT Antworten, die folgen alle so einem ähnlichen Muster.
Und so cool ich die Technik an sich finde, was mich ein bisschen nervt.
Aktuell ist das Reddit und Foren und sogar Discord teilweise
invaded wird von irgendwelchen ChatGPT Antworten.
Also du kannst quasi in Foren gar nicht mehr wirklich.
Darauf vertrauen, dass die Antworten, die auch dort geschrieben werden,
zumindest zumindest sagen wir mal wohlwollende,
Leute sind oder Stack Overflow, sondern dass da vieles, vieles Bots sind.
Glücklicherweise oder was heißt Bots?
Es können auch normale Leute sein, die einfach ChatGPT fragen und die Antwort reinpasten.
Das Problem bei ChatGPT Antworten ist halt, gerade wenn es um Seiten wie Stack Overflow und so geht,
wo Leute beispielsweise nach Programmier bei Programmier Problemen fragen, ist halt, dass Leute,
wenn die Antworten die Leute können zwar auch Mist antworten.
Ja, aber bei ChatGPT lesen sich die Antworten halt richtig pfeifert und sie sind einfach.
Manchmal auch nur im zweiten Abschnitt komplett falsch.
Ich habe gestern, ich habe gestern mal gefragt, wie ich.
SSH Multiplexing aktiviere.
Da kam raus, ich solle mir SSH Shuttle installieren, um darüber dann mit TMAX mein SSH zu multiplexen.
Und so was war auch irgendwie nicht so ganz richtig, als ich gefragt habe,
wie kann ich in meine SSH Config Multiplexing aktivieren?
Dann war die, dann war die Antwort richtig.
Also es ist einfach vieles verkehrt.
Und man muss halt sagen ChatGPT labert halt ohne Ende.
Und die Dinger, die Dinger sind immer, die Dinger sind immer ähnlich.
Die Antworten von ChatGPT, wenn du, wenn du ChatGPT fragst,
welcher Streamer hat den besten,
den besten Twitch Chat, da kommt die ChatGPT Ahnung dann so was wie die Frage nach dem besten Streamer.
Chat ist immer eine subjektive Frage.
Diese, diese, es hängt von vielen Faktoren ab.
Zum Beispiel der Streamer interagiert mit seinem Chat.
Wie häufig ist der Streamer selbst aktiv?
Und diese Frage erfordert mehrere Dings bla bla bla bla bla.
Also die Antworten sind immer ähnlich.
Und man kann auch sagen,
ich est hier gerade unter der Zeitung aufgebaut.
Da ist Copilot für direkte Fragen nach Kommandos tatsächlich besser.
Code Pilot sagt entweder keine Ahnung oder meistens was Sinnvolles.
Wo ChatGPT ganz gut ist, ist als Handbuchersatz.
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel ChatGPT fragt,
Moment, mach wir das, mach, mach wir doch grad mal.
Kommt mal gucken, mal gucken,
ob es heute nicht wieder überlastet ist.
Genau, also die Dieb...
Dieb...
Die, ja, gestern habe ich gehört, ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit ihnen los ist, I have no idea, what is wrong with yous, okay, was auch immer, also wir können mal fragen, chatgpt, ja, explain this command, rsync-va, kann man zum Beispiel fragen.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, geht's, und wenn wir Pech haben, ist es gerade wieder überlastet, dafür ist chatgpt wirklich ganz praktisch, man kann natürlich auch explain shell verwenden, das geht auch, okay, jetzt ist chatgpt gerade wieder am abkacken, ja, auch nochmal, ah, jetzt, hier, the command rsync-va is used to synchronize files in directories, okay, for a is verbose mode, a is archive mode, which preserves permission, die Antwort ist super, ja, die Antwort ist super,
damit kann man wirklich,
was anfangen, ja, gestern hattest du ja erwähnt, was ich vergessen habe, welche Wrapper-Tools verwendest du für chatgpt und CodePilot, ähm, das hier, Moment, äh, GitHub, einmal AI-ask für CodePilot und GitHub, äh, chatgpt-wrapper, ja, also einmal das hier, das funktioniert ohne, dass es was kostet, weil das quasi eine Browser-Sendung ist,
also das ist eine Browser-Sendung, poss geometric passion emuliert, im Hintergrund steuert das einen Browser-Fern, dementsprechend, wenn ihr einen Account habt und euch angemeldet habt, könnt ihr das kostenlos verwenden, so wie ihr es im Browser verwenden würdet.
Das hier ist für, das da, das hier ist für GitHub CodePilot, es steht nicht CodePilot da, aber es ist, es ist der gleiche, wie die CodePilot-Engine unten drunter.
Dafür braucht man aber einen API.
key und das kostet was und das ist gar nicht so billig leute guckt mal hier du
bezahlst fast also aktuell bezahlst du nix weil das beta ist und du 18 euro
startguthaben 18 dollar startguthaben hast aber du bezahlst bis zu bis zu
aufgerundet 2 cent pro abfrage gar nicht so billig also die api ist eigentlich zu
teuer für es täglich zu benutzen überlegt euch mal ich meine zwei cent
pro kommando wenn die antworten jedes mal wirklich on point und richtig geil
wären okay aber ansonsten ist es doch schon ein bisschen ein bisschen teuer
wer weiß wie oft du das am tag fragst wenn du dich wenn du dich dran dran
gewöhnt hast also
ja also aber das kann ich auf jeden fall empfehlen den chat gpt cli rapper
das kostet nix
weil er keine api keys und api benutzung bezahlen muss und brauchst
chat gpt login du machst machst und browser auflogs dich ein und dann kannst
es verwenden okay auf geht's zu einem thema oder personen seiner wahl gedichte
anfertigt und sogar auf eigene anweisungen hin ganzes programm oder
eine app programmieren kann persönlich bin ich davon überzeugt dass das schon
die nächsten ein bis zwei jahre die welt komplett verändern wird und eine
heftige revolution so ist wie das internet natürlich ist es
so
weltweit jetzt schon an schulen und ich glaube nicht dass es eine heftige
revolution wird wie das internet das internet war ja auch keine revolution in
dem in dem sinne das war ja auch über eine eine stetige entwicklung bis jetzt
hin über die letzten 40 jahre im zeitspann von millionen jahren schon und
es ist nicht so dass chat gpt von heute auf morgen jetzt irgendwie die welt
komplett verändert allerdings man sieht
sowohl positive als auch negative effekte ich muss das jetzt mal fast zu
formulieren wie eine chat gpt antwort diese ganze bot dieses ganze botting wird
natürlich auf neue auf komplett neues level gehoben also was instagram wenn ich
weiß was es deck overflow discord boards reddit bots und sowas angeht das ist
komplett neues level mit mit sinnlos antworten die halt direkt aus chat gpt
kommen
Sicherlich wird auch sehr viel E-Mail-Spam in Zukunft über ChatGPT generiert, aber ich warte noch auf die Kombination ChatGPT mit DeepL zum Übersetzen. Ich meine, ChatGPT kann auch translaten, aber dann kriegst du demnächst auf Nigerianisch geschriebene Dinger in Deutsch übersetzt aus ChatGPT und sowas. Ja, aber dass morgen der Terminator um die Ecke kommt, ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Unis, das Thema Nummer 1, ob man es verbieten soll oder nicht.
Warum sollte man das verbieten? Was ist mit den Leuten los, Mann? Wer sagt das?
Unis, ob man es verbieten soll oder nicht.
Natürlich ist es weltweit jetzt schon an Schulen und Unis das Thema Nummer 1, ob man es verbieten soll oder nicht.
Ach so, ach so, ah, verstehe, an Unis und Schulen. Ah ja, okay, ja.
Die Sache ist die, du wirst es doch kaum verbieten können. Wie willst du das verbieten?
Du kannst sagen...
Ha, ihr dürft kein ChatGPT nehmen, um eure Hausaufgaben zu machen.
Ja, und? Wie willst du das wirklich schlüssig aktuell belegen, dass es ChatGPT ist?
Es gibt Tools, die das versuchen und theoretisch kannst du natürlich als Lehrer eine recht hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit rausfinden, ob das aus ChatGPT ist.
Weil du kennst ja den Input-Text, du kennst ja deine Frage, die du gestellt hast.
So, und wenn du die Frage dann selbst auf ein paar AI-Plattformen eingibst und dann Antworten generieren lässt, da siehst du ja schon ungefähr, was da rauskommt.
So wirklich richtig hundertprozentig wissen kannst du es nicht.
Allerdings, die Leute, die sind ja nicht dumm und die werden die Frage nicht eins zu eins stellen und die werden die Antwort wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen beantworten.
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, ist es denn noch eine AI-Antwort oder ist es denn ein eigenes Werk des Schülers?
Also, wenn jemand sich mit AI was generieren lässt und das als Grundlage nimmt für eine eigene Antwort, dann ist es schwierig zu sagen, dass es jetzt AI generiert oder nicht.
Vor allem wirst du es nicht rauskriegen.
Also, ich denke, verbieten ist an der Realität vorbei.
Zumal es auch die Gefahr birgt, dass wenn jemand was schreibt, was zu ähnlich ist, aber gar nicht aus Chat-GPT kommt, dass dann der Lehrer sagt, ah, das hast du aus Chat-GPT.
Und dann will er vielleicht noch, dass du beweist, dass du das nicht aus Chat-GPT hast.
Wie willst du das machen?
Du kannst extrem schlecht beweisen, dass du was nicht gemacht hast.
Also, das ist schlecht.
Oh man.
Chat-GPT.
Gedicht über YouTuber MaxFPS.
Ich bin der YouTuber MaxFPS.
Oh, das ist so cringe, Alter.
Das klingt eher wie ein schlechter Hip-Hop-Text.
Das klingt einfach nur wie ein extrem schlechter Deutsch-Rap-Text.
Okay, es fehlt noch ein paar Mal das Wort Bitches und sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, ja, aber ansonsten könnte das...
Zehn Jahre alte Rapper.
Naja, das meiste, was es da so gibt, hört sich auch so an, als haben das Zehnjährige geschrieben.
Nur mit mehr Schimpfwort drinnen.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich schwierig zu sagen, weil du könntest im Endeffekt ja auch schon behaupten,
weil Chat-GPT trainiert ist auf Grundlage quasi bestehender Werke,
dass das, was da rauskommt, vielleicht auch schon nicht so ganz der Kreativität entsprungen ist.
Also, es ist schwierig zu sagen, ab welcher Stelle das ist.
Also, verbieten wird auf jeden Fall nicht funktionieren.
Da bin ich mir recht.
Relativ sicher.
Wie willst du es verbieten?
Die Leute werden es trotzdem, werden es trotzdem, ähm, trotzdem verwenden.
Also, das, das, das wird nicht klappen.
So.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ja, 3D-Drucker schreibt meine Hausaufgaben.
Ja, genau, genau.
Das ist auch bei GitHub.
Äh, was hörst du für eine Musik?
Ähm, also ich höre beim Arbeiten so, so 0815 YouTube Entspannungskram, ja, von irgendwelchen Chillstep-Compilations
bis irgendwelches Lolo.
Lofi-Zeug.
Das ist aber nicht Musik, die ich höre, weil ich Musik hören will.
Wenn ich Musik höre, wenn ich wirklich Musik hören will, höre ich meistens Heavy Metal.
Von Power-Metal bis Epik-Symphonie-Power-Metal und auch das eine oder andere Death-Metal.
Alle möglichen Sachen dabei.
Was ich überhaupt nicht gerne höre, ist tatsächlich Hip-Hop und Deutsch-Rap.
Außer Haftbefehl natürlich.
Haftbefehl wissen wir ja alle.
Beste.
Ich sage nur, Goethe-Straße.
Louis Vuitton-Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Ist das einzige Haftbefehl-Quote, was ich kann und was ich wahrscheinlich auch hier können werde.
Ne.
Auf dem Letzten.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen Schiss, aktuell auf Konzerte zu gehen.
Letzte Konzerte habe ich mit Corona eingefangen.
Und das war eigentlich gut durchlüftet im Frankfurter Stadion.
Okay, also.
Gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal an, was hier so abgeht.
Aber ich glaube, wir treiben das Ganze nochmal auf die Spitze, indem wir unseren 3D-Drucker beibringen.
Mit dem Wissen von ChatGPT.
Mit dem richtigen Kugelschreiber ganze Arbeitsblätter auszufüllen.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, also 3D-Drucker schreiben lassen mit dem Stift ist wahrscheinlich, also stelle ich mir jetzt persönlich nicht so schwierig vor.
Die ganze Movement-Logik und so ist schon da.
Man müsste sich jetzt nur überlegen, also Software, die quasi auf die eigene Handschrift trainiert, gibt es ja auch.
Man müsste sich jetzt nur überlegen, wie man eben das von dieser Software, die die eigene Handschrift, falls er das überhaupt macht,
wie man das translated gescheit bekommt in diesen, diesen, wie heißt?
Das, wie heißt dieses Steuerungs-Codes für 3D-Drucker nochmal?
Halten diese Steuerungs-Code, G-Code, genau.
Wie man das ordentlich in G-Code translated.
Und dann ist das ein Ding von wahrscheinlich sich auf GitHub zwei bis drei der richtigen Projekte raussuchen.
Und es ist, denke ich mal, relativ iets, sowas zu machen.
Also wahrscheinlich die drei passenden Shell-Befehle ineinander pipen.
Also ich müsste quasi jetzt mein ChatGPT.
Antwort, pipen in mein, wandle es in meine Handschrift um, pipe es in, wandle es in G-Code um und dann ein Curl auf mein OctoPi.
Dann würde es wahrscheinlich, und ich muss natürlich an meinen Drucker irgendwie einen Stift, irgendwie einen Stift rankriegen.
Seid bereit für das Unmögliche, seid bereit für die Zukunft.
Wieso unmöglich klingt das gar nicht?
Das sind meine Worte, sondern die von der KI.
Allah, mehr.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Steuerbot.
Dazu später.
Wie ein 3D-Drucker funktioniert, wisst ihr ja alle.
Im Grunde eine Mini-Heißklebepistole, die über alle drei Achsen angeschaltet werden kann und somit Schicht auf Schicht Kunststoff.
Eine Mini-Heißklebepistole, ja, gar nicht mal so verkehrt.
Es war kein Heißkleber, aber...
...fertig ist.
Für Handschrift...
Aber an sich ist die, ist die, hab ich noch nicht gehört, aber die Umschreibung ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Tatsächlich ist also nur die unterste Schicht und statt Kunststoff montieren wir einfach einen Stift an den Extruder.
Um dem 3D-Drucker zu sagen, wie er sich dann bewegen soll, könnte man problemlos 3D-Text erstellen und davon nur die unterste...
...Schicht drucken, beziehungsweise entschreiben lassen.
Das jedes Mal zu machen, wäre aber fast aufwendiger, als es selbst zu schreiben.
Wir haben also eine Lasersoftware zweckentfremdet und bekamen somit unsere ersten Ergebnisse.
Alter, der schreibt jetzt schon schöner als...
Der Stift ist halt noch nicht fest genug dran.
Komplett geil einfach.
Es muss schon fester dran sein.
Also man muss noch ein bisschen dran arbeiten, klar.
Aber es ist jetzt schon komplett geil.
Also er schreibt halt auch gerade rückwärts, ne, aber...
...ist letztendlich auch egal.
Und das F da hat er irgendwie komplett vergessen.
Also wenn das nicht komplett schöne Hausaufgaben sind...
Sieht ungefähr so aus, wie meine Hausaufgaben früher.
Es ist sehr authentisch.
Also ein Grund, warum das so hässlich ist, ist halt auch, dass der einfach die Buchstaben komisch verbindet.
Schreibt mal in die Kommentare, wer von euch eine Handschrift hat, die noch schlechter aussieht als das.
Ist schon ganz geil.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass der Stift halt irgendwie komplett wackelt, weil das Panzer tape.
Das sagt gerade aus, als will er den Stift rauchen, oder?
Ist schon ganz geil.
Es sieht aus, als zieht er gleich am Stift.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass der Stift halt irgendwie komplett wackelt, weil das Panzer tape.
Naja, gut.
Hier ist so eine Konstruktion, wo man den Stift einmal reinlegen kann.
Dann schraubt man das hier fest.
Und dann kann man das hier drauf schrauben.
Das Problem ist, da fehlt noch ein Loch.
Das wundert mich nicht, dass Leute dafür schon 3D gedruckte Sachen gebaut haben,
zum selbst 3D drucken, um eine Stifthalterung an seinen Extruder zu bauen.
Und drückt das Teil einmal drüber.
Und da bohre ich jetzt rein.
Lol.
Oha.
Hä, ist das voll geil.
Ja.
Alter, ist das eine schöne Schrift.
Es ist noch Englisch einfach, aber es ist komplett geil.
Und jetzt schreibt er gleich...
Auf die Platte.
Ja, gut.
Snooker.
Alter, das hab ich in der Grundschule geschrieben.
Also so hätten meine Eltern gewollt, dass ich in der Grundschule schreib.
Ich hab dann eher so geschrieben.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Print.
Oder hier mal eine andere Schrift hat.
Einfach Fuchs, du hast sie ganz gestohlen.
Es ist schon...
Ich mein, warum soll es nicht funktionieren?
Nein.
Kommen wir zum spaßigen Teil, also eigentlich dem nicht ganz so spaßigen Teil, den Hausaufgaben.
Ich hab hier, wie gesagt, echte Hausaufgaben aus der zweiten, der vierten, der achten und der zehnten Klasse.
Und die werden wir jetzt nacheinander probieren, ob die KI das so beantworten kann und ob der 3D-Drucker eine echt glaubwürdige Hausaufgabe damit abliefern könnte.
Viel interessanter wär's, ob, wie du dem 3D-Drucker beibringen willst, an welche Stelle er das auf das Arbeitsblatt schreiben muss.
Wenn nicht manuell.
Also, man kann natürlich das Blatt manuell justieren.
Fangen wir an mit der zweiten Klasse.
Das ist von einer guten Freundin, der Schlodde.
Und zwar ist die Aufgabe hier, schreibe die folgenden zehn Nomen mit bestimmten Artikeln...
Da hört schon, da fängt schon mal an, ich hab schon gar keine Ahnung mehr, obwohl das zweite Klasse ist.
Ich hätte schon gar keine Ahnung mehr, was Nomen überhaupt sind.
... mit bestimmten Artikeln auf, da hört's...
Wer weiß es?
Chat, Chat, was ist ein Nomen?
Auf geht's.
Chat, Chat, warum wisst ihr das nicht?
So, Nomen.
Sag Wikipedia.
Das ist ein...
Nomen als Oberbegriff der...
deklinierbaren Wortarten.
Jetzt sollte alles klar sein, oder?
Der lateinische Wort, das lateinische Wort, hatte in der Grammatik anfangs nur die Bedeutung von Eigenname.
Als Hauptkriterium für die allgemeine Wortart Nomen etablierte sich dann Wortarten, die einen Kasus tragen können.
Okay, ich bin jetzt noch verwirrter als vorher.
Eigenname gibt am ehesten noch Sinn.
Mehr ehrlich gesagt schon auf.
Okay, guck mal mal.
Wollen wir mal Chat-GPT fragen?
Ob Chat, Chat...
Was ist ein Nomen?
Okay, ich hab ein Leerzeichen gemacht.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Okay.
Bezahre eine Idee, es ist eine Art von Substantiv im Deutschen.
Aha.
Fuchs, Haus, Eimer und so weiter.
Beispiel, der Onkel und ein Onkel.
Verstehe.
Die Frage gehe ich jetzt einfach eins zu eins zu eine KI.
Der Onkel, ein Onkel, der Tisch, ein Tisch, der Fuchs, ein Fuchs, das Haus, ein Haus, der Eimer, ein Eimer.
Der Hund, ein Hund, das Fenster, ein Fenster.
Ich glaube, das ist überhaupt gar kein Stress.
Das kriegt KI.
Easy.
Ich schnapp mir jetzt mal ein Blatt.
Was haltet ihr denn von IFTT?
Ja, ganz, ganz nice.
Leider ein bisschen zu langsam, um da schnell...
Also, die haben ja, glaube ich, ein Zustell...
Kann bis zu fünf Minuten dauern.
Meistens geht es halbwegs schnell.
Aber Chat-GPT...
Also, nee, nicht Chat-GPT.
IFTT ist ein bisschen zu langsam, zum Beispiel für...
Ich drücke auf den Knopf und meine Tür soll aufgehen und sowas.
Ansonsten ist es von der Idee her ganz nice.
Ich habe es aber noch nie großartig verwendet.
Die müssen ja sogar mir auch geschrieben werden.
Shared-Foulers in VM, ne, verwende ich nicht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice, weil er wartet jetzt gerade.
Also, das Einzige, was ich share, ist manchmal mein komplettes Laufwerk.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, track-on-trop ich lieber in die VM und aus der VM raus.
Wo er den ersten Punkt gleich machen wird.
Und dadurch habe ich noch Gelegenheit...
Ah, man muss manuell platzieren, das Blatt.
...das Blatt festzumachen.
Oh mein Gott, er legt schon los.
Hilfe.
Das war jetzt nicht Absicht, aber es läuft.
Und jetzt schreibt er es einfach selber.
Ich finde das so geil.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die Handschrift ist auch richtig schön.
Ich habe extra eine Druckschrift genommen, weil, klar, in der Grundschule schreibt man Druckschrift.
Bei weitem nicht so schön.
Das ist logisch.
Und vor allem schreibt man deutlich schneller mit der Hand.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich in der Grundschule schreiben hätte sollen.
Er zieht einmal jeden Buchstaben durch, perfekt eins nach dem anderen.
Der Tisch, ein Tisch, der Fuchs, ein Fuchs macht er jetzt gleich.
Richtiger Fuchs.
Aber es ist schon eine äußerst schöne Schrift, ja.
Aber man ist von der Hand wahrscheinlich schneller.
Okay, vielleicht in der zweiten Klasse nicht.
Wobei, doch, selbst in der zweiten Klasse bist du schneller.
Wenn er jetzt die Hausaufgaben erledigt, dann chill ich auf YouTube.
War fertig.
Pam.
Ja, mega.
Das nenne ich doch mal Hausaufgaben.
Kann man so abgeben, würde ich sagen.
Also das wird dir kein Lehrer abkaufen, wahrscheinlich, dass du das gemacht hast.
Das ist ein echtes Arbeitsblatt.
Richtig.
Nice.
Schöner Muffin hier, schöner Hahn, richtig süß.
Tomi macht einen Ausflug mit der Klasse.
Er backt mit seiner Mama für alle Kinder Muffins.
Er plant für jedes Kind zwei Muffins ein.
Oder ein Textaufgaben.
28 Kinder.
Jetzt, jetzt vorbei.
Welche Fragen kannst du mithilfe des Textes beantworten?
Kreuze an.
Wie viele Muffins backt Tomi insgesamt?
Kann man beantworten.
Mit wem backt Tomi die Muffins?
Kann man auch beantworten.
Welche Muffins backt Tomi?
Kann man natürlich nicht beantworten.
Wie viele Kinder sind in Tomis Klasse?
Kann man auch beantworten.
Wohin macht Tomis Klasse den Ausflug?
Das kann man nicht beantworten.
Ihr seht, in welche Richtung die Aufgabe geht.
An welche Tabelle passt Kreuze an?
Kinder Muffins.
Das sind quasi einfach Verhältnisse, die zueinander stimmig sein müssen.
Wow.
Das ist ja fast wie die IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
Schauen wir mal, was die Karina dazu sagt.
Ich copy-paste jetzt das komplette Arbeitsblatt.
Einmal mal hier rein.
Dann schreibe ich dem mal noch dazu, wie das läuft.
Das heißt, er soll mir einfach hier eine Kreuze reinsetzen.
Das ist logisch.
Damit er das einmal versteht, wie er mir eine Antwort geben kann.
Dann mache ich Enter.
Zack.
Das ist erstmal ein bisschen was zum Bearbeiten.
Das dauert.
Das dauert jetzt erstmal eine Weile.
Das stimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist auch richtig.
Das ist auch richtig, dass man das nie ankreuzt.
Das kann man auch wissen, ja.
Man kann nicht wissen, wohin der Ausflug geht.
Ja, also alles richtig.
Welche Tabelle passt?
Die erste Tabelle sagt, er passt.
Die zweite Tabelle sagt, er passt nicht.
Stimmt auch.
Dann zweite Frage.
Da geht es nämlich um den Max, der am Bauernhof arbeitet.
Was?
Bei Max auf dem Bauernhof leben Hühner.
Er hat insgesamt 25 Hühner.
Die Hennen brüten.
Jedes Huhn kann 15 Eier mit den Federn warm halten.
Heute muss Max seine Hühner alleine füttern.
Welche Fragen kann man damit beantworten?
Und die beiden, die man beantworten kann.
Warte, stimmt das?
Wie viele Hühner leben bei Max auf dem Hof?
Ja.
Welche Tiere leben noch auf dem Hof?
Weiß man nicht.
Wie viele Eier kann ein Huhn warm halten?
Weiß man auch.
Wann muss Max morgen aufstehen?
Weiß man nicht.
Man weiß nicht, wie viele Eier ein Huhn legt.
Und man weiß auch nicht, wie viele Hühner braun oder weiß sind.
Perfekt.
Welche Tabelle passt?
Kreuze an.
Da hat er auch die richtige Tabelle angekreuzt.
Das heißt, vierte Klasse bestätigt.
Eats.
Richtig geil.
Multiple Choice.
Print.
Und let's go.
Wenn wir das positionieren.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, weil das ist tatsächlich das, was ich mir mit Abstand am
schwierigsten vorgestellt hätte.
Wie erkennst du oder wie platzierst du das platt, sodass du es nicht von Hand platzieren
musst?
Aber das macht er nicht.
Falls ich auch verstehen kann, das ist tatsächlich die mit Abstand schwierigste Sache an diesem
ganzen Ding.
Da müsstest du nämlich irgendwie die Position erkennen.
Also müsstest du das irgendwie mit Kamera ausrichten, dann irgendwie Offset machen,
wo der Drucker anfangen soll.
Gar kein Stress für den.
Kreuze einfach an.
Zack, zack.
Alle richtigen Antworten.
Komplett easy.
Es ist einfach.
Ja, und wie hat er das jetzt umgewandelt in G-Code?
Außer irgendwie von Hand in einem 3D.
Das ist doch der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Also wie kommt das von ChatGPT, wie wird das in G-Code umgewandelt?
Das ist nämlich auch, weil ChatGPT kennt nicht die Abstände zwischen den Zeilen und
sowas.
Das muss man dann alles von Hand in einem 3D-Programm machen, oder wie?
Ja, das ist ja das eigentlich Interessante daran.
Pam, fährt rüber und fertig.
Drei Sekunden.
Hausaufgabe einfach.
Fertig.
Kommen wir zur achten Klasse.
Ich habe hier auch wieder ein echtes Arbeitsblatt, zweiseitig diesmal, von meiner Schwester.
Ja, also wenn ihr die Frau Lehmann...
Laser-Gravierungssoftware, ja, das ist schön und gut, aber das musst du ja irgendwie in
die Laser-Gravierungssoftware reinbekommen.
Ja.
Wenn ihr einen Werken-Unterricht habt und man sieht auch direkt, dass hier in der...
Okay, okay, das probiere ich mal.
Ähm, schreibe die Antwort in G-Code.
Schreibt man das mit Minus?
Okay, da war keine Kamera.
Okay, das kann es nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwie Sinn ergibt, was da gerade rauskommt.
Jetzt müsste man wirklich mal gucken, was eigentlich...
Was dieser G-Code macht.
Online-G-Code-Viewer.
Moment, wie selekte ich so hier?
Das da, oder?
Ja, das funktioniert nicht.
Hat jemand...
Kennt jemand da was Gutes?
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Uh, was ist das denn?
Du hast die Hälfte nicht mitkopiert?
Doch.
Ich habe doch alles kopiert.
Ich habe alles...
Ich habe alles kopiert hier.
Guck, das da.
Ach, nee.
Das habe ich nicht.
Ähm.
Web-G-Code.
Okay.
Ich muss mal wegmachen.
Habe ich was vergessen?
Ah, fuck.
Da ist ja noch mehr.
Da ist ja noch mehr drin.
Shit, jetzt habe ich alles, oder?
Okay, zack.
Zack.
F50 fehlt.
Ah.
Ja.
Nicht so wirklich.
Das funktioniert nicht so...
Das funktioniert nicht so wirklich, was Chat-GPT da gemacht hat.
Ja.
Irgendwie so ein Strich.
Nein, der sollte die Antwort in G-Code schreiben.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Zwei Linien.
Ja.
Also.
Das klappt so nicht.
...klasse, der ernst des Lebens beginnt, weil hier einfach kein cooler Muffin mehr ist.
Und man einfach nur noch...
Ja.
Zeilen halt.
Das Arbeitsblatt 1 zu 1.
Copy-Paste ich jetzt hier rein.
Zack.
Ich habe ihm vorher gesagt, wie das mit der Tabelle funktioniert.
Weil Tabelle per Text...
Das ist keine echte Tabelle, aber er versteht das.
Was führte zur Herstellung von Kunststoffen?
Die Entwicklung von synthetischen Materialien und chemischen Prozessen führte zur Erfindung von Kunststoffen.
Zweitens.
Am Beginn der Kunststoffentwicklung stand die Umwandlung von Naturstoffen mithilfe von Zusatzstoffen und halbsynthetischen Kunststoffen.
Ergänze dazu die nachfolgende Tabelle.
Darauf bin ich jetzt richtig gespannt, denn ich kenne die ganzen Lösungen noch gar nicht.
Ich erfahre die jetzt erst, wie die hier draufgeschrieben werden.
So, ich positioniere das Blatt und es wird geschrieben.
Diesmal übrigens in Schreibschrift.
Weil, klar, in der Grundschule schreibt man...
Jetzt muss ich ihm sagen, das ist die falsche Art.
Ich kann ihm nichts sagen, weil ich keine...
Nicht so einfach Dialog machen kann damit.
Aber irgendwann wird einem Schreibschrift klargebracht.
Klar, also ich persönlich schreibe mittlerweile auch wieder Druckschrift, weil Schreibschrift komplett Schwachsinn ist.
Aber trotzdem geil, dass er halt einfach alle möglichen Schriftarten beherrscht.
Und dass das jetzt wirklich mal eine Weile dauert.
Exquisite Musik hier.
Perfekt, wie gewohnt.
Naja, bis auf die eine Stelle.
Ich meine, ja, also auch der Dreck hier drüber macht einen Fehler.
Und ich meine, besser.
Ein Punkt Abzug als die Hausaufgabe selber zu schreiben, würde ich mal meinen.
Was steht denn drin?
Kunsthorn wird aus Casin und Formaldehyd gemacht.
Genau.
Dann Zelluloid wird aus Zellulose und Kupfer gemacht.
Erkläre den Begriff synthetische Stoffe mit eigenen Worten.
Recherchiere dazu auch im Internet.
Kann die KI nicht, aber trotzdem hat sie es wahrscheinlich gewusst.
Synthetische Stoffe sind Stoffe, die durch menschliche Technologien und Chemie hergestellt werden, anstatt aus natürlichen Ressourcen.
Das ist eine Fangfrage.
Leute, das ist eine Fangfrage, je nach Lehrer.
Wisst ihr, was passiert?
Recherchiere auch im Internet.
Das machen die Leute.
Und dann kommt der Lehrer und sagt, Wikipedia gilt nicht als Antwort.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist so eine Fangfrage.
Der will wissen, der will die Leute direkt flamen dafür, dass sie was von Wikipedia nehmen.
Es gibt ja immer noch Lehrer, die sagen, Wikipedia ist der Teufel, so nach dem Motto.
Menschliche Technologien und Chemie hergestellt werden, anstatt aus natürlichen Ressourcen.
Meine Schwester war so nett und hat mir einen Lösungsvorschlag mitgeschickt.
Darunter versteht man Künstler.
Künstlich hergestellte Stoffe, also Kunststoffe.
Ich würde sagen, da kann man den Punkt geben.
Dann Nummer 4.
Wie heißt der erste vollsynthetische Kunststoff, der hergestellt wurde?
Bakelit ist auch richtig.
Oh, dann fehlt noch die zweite Seite.
Die müssen wir natürlich auch noch machen.
So, und er schreibt.
Wenn du Quelle Wikipedia sagst, wird dir der Lehrer dann eins reinwürgen, je nachdem, wie er drauf ist.
Ja, wo haben sie das dann her?
Wikipedia.
Ah, Wikipedia als Quelle.
Oh, also das war jetzt auf jeden Fall mal ein Text, den ich nicht schreibe.
Und hier diesmal auch perfekt in den Zeilen.
Richtig gut geworden.
Okay, also die meisten Kunststoffe sind heutzutage vollsynthetisch.
Nennen die drei Ausgangsstoffe vollsynthetische Kunststoffe.
Kohlen, Wasserstoffe, Erdöl und Erdgas.
Die richtige Lösung wäre Erdöl.
Jeder Stoff ist aus natürlichen Ressourcen hergestellt.
Naja, du kannst ja theoretisch auch Elemente herstellen, die es natürlich nicht gibt.
Die haben meistens eine relativ kurze Haltbarkeit.
Aber ich weiß, was du sagen willst.
Und wird dir natürlich recht.
Im Prinzip, aber rein theoretisch nicht.
Du kannst zum Beispiel Elemente herstellen, die natürlich nicht vorkommen, weil es eben keine stabilen Atome formen.
Zum Beispiel gibt es da, oh was gibt es da, Kalifornium oder sowas gibt es glaube ich.
Weißt du was so, Kalifornium 252.
Ja.
Ist ein künstlich erzeugtes Chemisch.
Ein chemisches Element mit dem bla bla bla bla.
Das Problem ist, dass diese Dinger meistens nur sehr kurz halten.
Erdgas und Kohle, ich würde sagen, das passt.
Was versteht man...
Ja, Darmstadium, das gibt es tatsächlich auch.
... unter Biokunststoffen.
Biokunststoffe sind Kunststoffe, die aus natürlichen biologisch abbaubaren Ressourcen wie Pflanzenfasern der Mikroorganismen hergestellt werden.
Sie haben den Vorteil, dass sie biologisch abbaubar sind und somit die Umweltbelastung durch Plastikmüll reduzieren.
Ich finde das...
... geil.
Mich hat es überzeugt.
Meiner Meinung nach steht einem Vorrücken in die nächste Klasse nichts im Weg.
Die neunte Klasse wird direkt übersprungen.
Es geht jetzt in die zehnte Klasse und das Interessante ist hier auch, wo in der vierten Klasse noch so richtig schöne Muffins abgebildet waren, in der achten hat man dann so ein normales Eisbad.
In der zehnten Klasse kriegst du dann auch noch irgendeinen langweiligen Text.
Das ist aber praktisch für uns, den können wir einfach copy-pasten.
Die kommt tatsächlich von Stolles Bruder, also auch danke an den.
Und let's go.
Alter, ist ja gut, übertreibbar, die Musik ist ja...
Das ist ein Brett.
Also das ist eine riesen Seite.
Hinten und vorne bedruckt, also wirklich wild, extrem viel Text.
Auch mega geil geschrieben, hier nirgends in der Zeile verrutscht, hier ist wirklich alles perfekt logisch.
Ist ja auch ein Computer.
Und ich fange jetzt einfach mal an, inhaltlich.
Die Aufgabe, erkläre die Begriffe Gleichschaltung und Selbstgleichschaltung.
Und ich lese nochmal mal vor.
Gleichschaltung bezieht sich auf die Anpassung oder Angleichung an ein bestimmtes politisches oder ideologisches System,
oft durch den Einsatz von Gewalt oder durch Druck von Regierungen oder Machteliten.
Selbstgleichschaltung hingegen bezieht sich auf den Prozess,
bei dem Individuen,
Kulturen oder Gruppen von sich aus ihre Ansichten, Überzeugungen oder Verhältnisweisen an das herrschende System anpassen, ohne...
Quasi Twitter.
...dass dazu Gewalt oder Druck ausgeübt werden muss.
Ich finde es extrem beängstigend, dass eine KI sowas kann.
Vor allem, die hat das nicht einfach so gegoogelt oder so, sondern die versteht das direkt.
Richtig krass, also extrem heftig.
Ich würde sagen, die Hausaufgaben sind ordentlich gemeistert.
Es ist auch gerade überall in Deutschland mega der Skandal,
weil alle möglichen Studenten das halt nutzen für ihre Prüfungen.
Und ich könnte mir irgendwie vorstellen, dass sich jetzt ganz viele Studenten und Schüler irgendwie einen 3D-Drucker kaufen.
In der Schule musste ich mich früher oft mit Papierkram rumschlagen, aber Papier...
Das ist doch offensichtlich, dass das...
Also die interessanteste Frage, wie er das in G-Code umwandelt, ja,
beziehungsweise wie er es in sein 3D-Dings-Programm reinkriegt...
Jo...
Okay, war jetzt nicht so spannend.
Und?
Die Switch ist halt an. Und weiter?
Soll... Geräte sollen benutzen und eigentlich überleben.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ach, Burn-In. Ja, naja.
Haben sie damals auch immer bei Plasma-Fernsehern und alten Röhrenmonitoren immer Panik geschoben.
Oh, da Burn-In!
Bei den meisten ist überhaupt nichts passiert. Großartig.
Ich habe Probleme, meine Tasmota-Geflechte direkt aus meinem UniFi-WLAN anzubinden.
Eine Idee, warum?
Ja, please check Credentials, diese stimmen hundertprozentig.
Ähm...
Was hast du bei dem UniFi eingestellt für WLAN-Standards, was da unterstützt wird?
Kann durchaus sein, dass deine Tasmota-Steckdosen das nicht alles können.
Und du WPA2-Kompatibilität wieder oder zusätzlich...
Ja, genau, oder... Na gut, bei 5 GHz wird er gar nicht sagen, Credentials falsch, oder?
Dann können wir das WLAN erstmal gar nicht finden.
WPA1 und 2...
Das sollte eigentlich...
...kein Problem machen.
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung...
Dann würde er aber immer nicht sagen, Passwort falsch.
Du könntest mal in das Log von deinem UniFi gucken, falls das sowas hat.
Ob der überhaupt erkennt, dass ein Client versucht sich zu verbinden und das ablehnt.
Das wäre nämlich auch schon mal was, weil vielleicht ist die Fehlermeldung, please check Credentials, eine Fehlermeldung, die immer kommt.
Egal, was es für Probleme gibt.
Das muss gar nichts mit Credentials zu tun haben.
Vielleicht ja auch das Problem, dass das WLAN nicht richtig gefunden wird, was auch immer.
Muss man mal gucken.
Kann man so jetzt nicht sagen.
Leute, wir fragen Chat-GPT nochmal schnell was.
Und zwar... Hallo?
Darf ich da please mal?
Ähm...
Was soll ich heute für ein Video aufnehmen?
Das müssen wir anders fragen.
Zu welchem Thema soll ich heute ein Video aufnehmen?
Das ist die typische Chat-GPT Antwort, die ich erwartet habe.
Das ist immer so super verträglich und alles formuliert.
Super diplomatisch.
Wenn sie sich...
Ein aktuelles Ergebnis oder ein interessantes Thema in ihrer Branche sprechen.
Sie können auch eine Anleitung, ein Tutorial...
Ja gut, das ist mir schon klar.
Okay, wir lassen uns mal...
Wir lassen uns mal kurz ein Clickbait...
Ein Clickbait...
Ähm...
Clickbait-Titel generieren.
Ich weiß nicht...
Ich generiere ein Clickbait-Titel...
Zum Thema...
Emulator...
Mini...
PC...
Oder so.
Okay, das mag er nicht.
Oder ist wieder überlastet.
Entdecke die unglaubliche...
Leistung...
Des neuen Emulator-Mini-PCs.
Du wirst es...
Nicht glauben.
Okay, schau mal gar nicht schlecht.
Gar nicht schlecht.
Machen wir mal...
Genere 5 Clickbait-Titel...
Zum Thema...
Ähm...
Können wir das Thema...
Bester...
Was würde ich denn?
Wie würde ich das denn nehmen?
Bester...
Diese kleine Kiste verändert dein Wohnzimmer.
Hey, das ist ein super Titel.
Den speichere ich mir mal.
Entdecke den ultimativen Mini-PC-Emulator.
Der perfekte Begleiter für deine Arbeit...
Dieser Mini wird dein Leben...
Hahaha...
Du wirst es nicht glauben.
Lass dich vom...
Also...
Der beste YouTube-Titel...
Der beste YouTube-Titel ist wahrscheinlich...
Ist wahrscheinlich...
Der hier.
Aber das ist schon so ausgelutscht...
Mittlerweile.
Diese Formulierung gibt es ja tausendfach.
Das ist ja auch schon langweilig.
Dieser Mini-PC-Emulator wird dein Leben verändern.
Du wirst es nicht glauben.
Verwende deinen alten Computer...
Okay, nochmal.
Ja, fünf Stück.
Ne, die nächsten fünf.
Ah ne, nochmal.
Der beste auf dem Markt.
Der beste Emulator für Mini...
Spiel aber in Stream in einem.
Hole das Beste aus deinen Mini-PCs.
Der ultimative Emulator im Test.
Aber Chat,
diese kleine Kiste verändert...
dein Wohnzimmer.
Finde ich einen super Titel.
Ah, Moment.
Wir machen nochmal was anderes.
Für YouTube.
Ein YouTube-Titel müsste ein bisschen kürzer sein.
Zehn Emulatoren im Vergleich.
Naja, nicht...
Nicht so wirklich, oder?
Nicht so wirklich.
Wie könnte man das Thema...
Könnte man das Thema besser beschreiben?
Beste Mini-PC für...
Ja, machen wir es mal so.
Probieren wir es mal so.
Ne, okay, okay.
Erlebe die Zukunft des Gamings.
Der Mini-PC...
der alle Emulationsträume...
wahrmacht.
Das ist legit nicht schlecht.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Okay, bester Mini-PC für...
Retro...
oder für...
für...
Retrogames...
Emulation.
Aber der hier ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Das...
Das ultimative Emulationsergebnis...
Das ist...
Ohne Scheiß, so mies ist das gar nicht.
Das geht tatsächlich.
Das ist...
Natürlich nicht alles.
Mini-PC Revolution.
Entdecke den ultimativen PC für Retrogaming Emulation.
Der beste Mini-PC für deine Lieblingsretrospiele.
Retrogaming...
Der beste Mini-PC.
Lass die Vergangenheit wieder aufheben.
Der beste Mini-PC für Retrogaming.
Retrospiele wie nie zuvor.
Der ultimative Mini-PC für...
Das ist...
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Also, muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube ich lasse demnächst noch ein paar Titel...
Ich meine,
ich bin unkreativ as fuck, was Titel angeht.
Also kann ich mir z.B. meine Chat-GPT holen.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt futtern.
Wir sehen uns. Bis an.
Mach's Gut.
See You.